let me know when you're ready christina
please
all right all set
okay thank you
all of you who are watching online uh
welcome to the
municipal county government committee
here march 1st
his chair
my name is tom dolan as chair of the
house municipal and county government
committee signed that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covert 19 pandemic
and in accordance with the governor's
emergency order
number 12 pursuant to the executive
order 2020-04
but this public body is authorized to be
electronically
this is a committee or this is a
committee meeting please know there is
no physical location for remembrance of
the public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this need however
in accordance with the emergency order i
am confirming that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting to the zoom
electronic meeting platform and the
public has access to contemporaneously
listen and if necessary to participate
in this meeting by the same platform or
by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general port website
to notice this meeting
complies with house rules and rsa 911a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271
or email
hcs
leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned
and reschedule
christina daya a mini researcher
will be on the staff assisting us
please note that all votes
taken during this meeting will be done
by a roll call book
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please also state whether
there's anybody in the room with you
during this meeting if you're if you're
on zoom which is required under the
right to number one
mr clerk representative dolan here
mr pmrt
president
is attending another meeting he will
join us since our
family
good to see you
representative chip
president
representative guthrie
here
representative losales here
mcbride
here
representative melvin yeah
talking to the phone
if you're on zoom we need you to
only identify that here but if you're
alone
uh where you are
so uh representative bryant can you do
that again
we have to unmute i'm sorry
representative mcbride just need you to
know if you're
if you're alone in the room you're at
yeah i'm in the lab at work
okay uh representative melvin
here
i show up senator absent excuse
uh representative pimentel
president in a room by myself
thank you representative power
here i'm at my home in brookline in my
office alone however there's another
family member elsewhere in the house
representative porter
i'm here in hillsborough i'm alone in
the room but my husband and cats are in
the house
representative trail evan
good morning mr clerk i am here in dover
new hampshire by myself downstairs and
the cat's taking a nap upstairs
what's up gilman is excuse absent
president majority
thank you i am here alone in my office
in northampton
representatives davis
my apologies i am present i'm here in my
home in west lebanon and i am alone
thank you representative meganfooty
namaste i am here in my home in nashua
i'm alone my husband will be coming in
around 2pm
representative
i am at my house in peterborough my
husband is in the other room and there
are dogs
representative
i am here alone
in
my family room
in nashua my husband is in the house um
as are my two greyhounds who noses will
appear every now and again um thank you
thank you
representative gallagher
i am here in my apartment in concord and
i'm alone
okay and representative
i'm sorry it's not joining the ship
you'll join us
is completed
okay thank you
all right we're gonna start our uh
our testimony today on house bill 431
which is relative to the
responsibilities of an elected animal
control officer
we have with us in the llb
[Music]
sponsor of the bill and
for you
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
members of tiffany for the record my
name is representative scott wallace
from county district 12 town of danville
um house bill 431
is a
house cleaning measure that will seek to
have the same accountability and
oversight of the road agent
position in any town that has an elected
animal control officer position
presently the town of danville has an
elected aco
and
when the warren article passed um
the warrant article was
rather short and did not have any
oversight or accountability provisions
in said one article so this particular
bill
we just provide for oversight and
accountability of the position
and it's as simple as that
this position has been back and forth
between a uh
an appointed position by the border
selectmen
subsequently made an electric position
then back to an appointed position and
now apparently an elected position so
over the past decade there's been um
some gaps in coverage and services
needed in these particular areas hence
this particular bill to make things a
little more streamlined and get the
citizens in danville and the animals in
danville a little bit better in
streamlined care with proper oversight
and accountability and it's as simple as
that
and i'd be happy to take any questions
at this point in time
anybody have questions for
representative wallace
mr i do
yes representative
please go ahead
thank you thank you for taking my
question
representative wallace is this position
an elected position across the state or
only specific to some counties
thank you for the question
representative it's my understanding
that danville may be the only town with
an elected aco in the state although i'm
not 100 certain of that
but that being said any elected position
in any town needs to have oversight and
accountability
especially for uh background checks for
to ensure that we have the appropriate
people uh in these positions um this is
not about the person that holds the bill
uh she's been hosted position presently
this is about anybody that holds any
elected position in any municipality in
the state
any other questions
yes representative porter has her hand
up mr chair yes please go ahead
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um
the town clerk in hillsborough was
elected
would that mean that the select board
has authority over her
can you answer that question for me
and the select board
discipline the town clerk
to your
knowledge that's an excellent question
i'm not sure of that but i suspect that
there is oversight
uh and accountability for all positions
um
you know in the event of any
male administration or uh
misconduct there is there is a method of
redress uh in the town i'm certain
thank you
representative uh
thank you mr chairman um so if i got
this correct
this is the only town that has an
elected
animal control officer right now is that
is that correct
that appears to be the case
representative and a follow-up uh mr
chairman yes please go ahead
so
my guess is it's the prerogative of the
town itself
to decide to have it either elected or
an or a um a non-elected position is
that correct
that is correct and typically when uh
elected officials
are put into a position there are
if that's done by a warrant article the
the details of the authority and
oversight are incorporated into said
warren article which didn't happen which
was probably just an oversight in this
case i don't believe it was there was
any nefarious or malicious malicious
intent that oversight and accountability
wasn't written into the ward article
and that's why this bill is coming
forward just because of
its administrative challenge for the
town presently as you can imagine
um
the position was an appointed position
as recently as two years ago and as long
as 10 years ago and it's going back and
forth a couple of times in the interim
uh
mr chairman could i have a third
follow-up i'm sorry yes go ahead
thank you
um so
i'm
i don't want to sound so
if if they can change it from
elected to non-elected and back and
forth
why are we as a legislature getting
involved
in the town's issues
thank you for the question uh
the reason is as this has gone back and
forth so many times uh we don't have
when the the people of the town and the
animals in the town are not getting the
level of service
that they should be getting okay so
we're looking to tighten that up
and
absent a another warrant article the
only method by which to do this is to
make it a parallel position just like
all other elected positions like the
road agent which reports to the board of
selectmen every position including ours
we do have uh oversight and
accountability in some manner um
and
currently the uh the elected aco also
sits on the board of selectmen which
would be the oversight and governing
body
so what's the problem
okay uh before i go to the next uh
question i just wanted to report we've
had a lot of folks sign in on this build
we've had 156 people sign in to support
the bill and 47 sided
to oppose the bill
next i'd like to recognize mr graves
from the nhma who poses
hello mr chair this is nate gray's new
hampshire municipal association can you
hear me all right yes
thank you so we are taking
no uh position on the bill
uh we we did have a suggestion
which was that uh the committee amended
the bill to move
the
the reference from chapter 42 to chapter
41.
and
the reason for that is the sponsor
places this
bill in chapter 42
uh which is the oath taken by town
officers uh chapter
and it seemed more appropriate that
would be chapter 41 which is the
uh the chapter which
which basically lists all of the
different positions um in the town and
whether they're elected appointed or
whether the town has an option for that
any questions for mr graves
seeing that i recognize representatives
davis
mr chair i don't believe i had my hand
up raised okay i thought i'd start a
next
all right next
we'll go to
representative blasek who supports the
bill
okay representative lasik's not
available let's go to
representative horrigan who poses
mr chair i don't see either
representative listed here the two
representatives on the sheet that i have
excuse me the two people on the sheet
sheila johansen and stacy ober are both
on the list but i don't see the two
people you named
can we see uh karen testament
i do not
and lastly timothy mcnamara
all right
let's go i think to there to testify on
other bills
yes you're right i'm sorry 431 only has
two yes you are thank you
let me ask
i'd like to ask a couple questions who
would provide the oversight and
accountability
for design of wellness
support selectmen just like we currently
do with road agents that is correct
and
any other questions from the committee
yes
this way oh yes i'm sorry representative
thank you uh i'm a selectman in a
uh a an adjoining
town of hampstead and uh slutman
uh there also and it seems to me that
this
bill does what we would like to see done
in
and is done in most every town
uh but it does not i think it's we've
been misled somewhat
uh that this
position is still elected will continue
to be elected unless the town changes
from elected to unappointed my
understanding is that this bill does
nothing other than make sure that there
is some accountability
within the town by the selectmen uh or
for anybody that's sitting in this
position that's elected
that's correct
so it doesn't take
take the position out of the elected
category and put it in appointed that is
correct thank you
thank you one last question from the
chair
to representative wallace why is this
needed now after after uh
what you've been through
thank you for the question mr chairman
this is needed now because the town
electric voted to make the animal
control officer position an elected
position but the warren article doing so
did not specify the ways and means by
which the position would be governed
this bill simply sets forth a manner by
which the position shall be administered
thank you any any uh final questions
for representative wallace
i'm seeing none
i'm going to close the hearing oh mr
chair i'm sorry i there are two uh there
are two people who still still wish to
speak on this bill who have who did sign
up sheila johansen and stacy ober
let's recognize
ms joe hanson who's speaking in
opposition
okay and i have just um
i believe just a lot there we go okay i
all set
yes
good morning thank you for letting me
speak
um
first of all um
mr wallace
um
citizens petitions
um can be done by any citizen
as long as you have 25 signatures that
are registered voters i want to let you
know
he should remind you
that yes in fact
the original
citizen's petition
and i'll read it to you um state
direct the border selectmen and the
chief of police regarding animal control
position
it read
with the signatures on there
to see if the town will vote to direct
the border selectmen and the chief of
police to employ
the elected animal control officer
position as a paid employee of the town
of danville
and to not delegate or contract the
airman control officer position said
animal control officer duties shall be
those as detailed in the 2011 animal
control officer description
said the animal officer position shall
also be initially compensated at no less
than two thousand eleven funding amount
the animal control officer position is
an elected not appointed position and
this vote shall take effect immediately
following march two thousand fourteen
as all as all um
procedures go
um a town town deliberative session
um shortened that
that petition as they can do and that is
why you didn't see what you saw
the town deliberative session
um
cut down the
what was what was the signatures for and
it came to
be voted on as to see if the town will
vote to require that the animal control
officer position be reinstated and be
yearly elected yearly as permitted by
the new hampshire
rsa 41 colon 2
so that the animal control officer will
be on the town ballot in march 2013.
i will also let you let um
committee know
that
a lot of these citizens petitions as
they were voted on were changed at
deliberative session and there was at
one point um
trying to get my things yet
while miss johansen is collecting the
thoughts uh i asked the committee to
consider it
uh very testimony now is not
for the purpose of questioning
representative wallace but it's to
provide testimony
to the
opposed bill please continue
uh another one that was done that was
voted on and it was also shortened
and i'll read this one as well
to see if the town will vote to require
and direct the board of selectmen and
chief of police that the animal control
officer position be reinstated
and be elected yearly pursuant to the
new hampshire 41 colon 2.
the elected and controlled position
shall employ
the elected young control officer
position as paid employee of the town of
danville not to delegate or contract the
un controlled position
dead almond control office's duties job
description and standard operating
procedures shall be those detailed in
the rockingham superior court march 5th
final order of motion of
summary judgment permanent court
injunction
uh decision
skill johansson versus town of danville
number two 218-214
dash cv-00442
the animal control officer position is
elected not appointed position said
animal control officer position
shall be initially compensated if no
less than 2017 budget amount this vote
takes place immediately following the
march 2018 position that also was
cut down
um to a short
one or two lines when it was passed
and i have something written out that
kind of he kind of threw me off when he
was talking about what he talked about
mr hanson do you have what you're
speaking to do you have that in writing
i do
can you make sure that if you haven't
already if you could forward it to the
committee
i can i i can i can do that
um now let me go back to what i should
have started with
and before you continue i want to let
the record show that representative
lang has ju has joined us as of 9 30.
thank you please continue
okay um so my name is sheila johansen
and i've been an animal control officer
for 17 years in the town now now in the
town of danville an elected animal
patrol officer since 2015.
what does an animal control officer do
the young control officer enforces state
laws in town ordinances pertaining to
domestic animals and provides education
and information for mitigating wildlife
issues animal control is dedicated to
serving the community as it relates to
both humans and animals
there are approximately 85 towns in new
hampshire that have young patrol
officers most are appointed
physicians and are not police officers i
am the only one that i'm aware of that
has an elected animal control officer
which is in danville
house bill 431 has nothing to do with
its title this bill is set up or
so-called amended to disenfranchise the
voters
um from 2004 to 2011
the danville aco was an appointed
position
in april of 2011 it was
it was i was not reappointed for the for
the uh position
uh citizen's petition was put forth
um
it was
it was um voted on
and it was um to see if the town would
vote to require the animal control
officer position to be reinstated and
elected yearly as permitted by the new
hampshire rsa 41 colon 2
so that the animal control office will
be on the town ballot for march 23
2013.
this
um and we are
i don't know if you realize what the
optional officers for 442 41 colon 2 are
but that reads
in addition to the offices which towns
are here and after required to elect at
an annual meeting any town may choose
one or more collectors of taxes agents
overseers of public welfare constables
police chiefs and other officers and
every other officer who may be directed
by law
to be chosen
in such other offices as it may judge
necessary for managing its affairs who
shall perform the duties
prescribed by law
constables police chiefs and police
officers shall be elected pursuant to
provisions of 41
colon 47.
um
when the danville police department and
the board of selectmen chose to not
so that that petition passed
when the danville pd and board of
selectmen chose not to abide by the
town's voters another citizen's petition
of more than 50 registered voters was
put forth again
and on march 2014 i ran for the elected
animal control officer position
um danville police officer um
cooper
also ran for the position
and
i received 394 votes and officer cooper
received 194.
the board of selectmen also placed a
warrant article to dissolve the elected
animal control officer position which
was defeated
again the board of selectmen and the
chief of police wade parsons refused to
allow me to do the elected job i then
filed a lawsuit against the town on
behalf of the town voters of which we
won and i say we
as it was the town voters that won
on march 5th 2015
the case number 2002 218-214
2014 dash
cv
00442 sheila johansen versus the town of
danville
is when the final order was was issued
through this court order an elected
animal control officer
job description and an elected animal
control officer standard operating
procedure
was accomplished and developed through
both both sides legal councils myself
the board of selectmen and chief wayne
parker
since 2015 there have been citizens
petitions placed on the ballot to
dissolve by a few residents
in 2017
it did it did pass to dissolve by 24 24
votes and this in the police department
did the job for one year
the following year was reinstated as
elected again by the citizens by a
citizen's petition where it still
remains elected in their attempts to
dissolve continue to be defeated
while the voters continue to support
their elected animal control officer
position
they also continue to support them so
that the position is paid without
battles from the from the board of
selectmen each year for the budget
an article 2020
was about the
animal control officer uh compensation
and um
that goal was on the warren article was
to ensure compensation for an animal
control officer and to include the
compensation of the animal control
officer position through the operating
budget
process in the future
danville is the only town in new
hampshire that i'm aware of that has an
elected young patrol officer danville
voters know what they want this bill is
nothing but an attempt to take away the
voter's choice this is clearly a town
issue not a statewide issue it's an
ongoing
battle of power and small town politics
by a few people
representative wallace clearly living in
this town is aware and is just trying to
backdoor our right to vote in shoes
since since the voters have clearly
spoken each time they have tried to
dissolve
the elected animal control position
the elected animal
elected position is elected each year by
the voters
as per the new hampshire rsa 41 colon 2
optional officers
i just got one more final thing sorry i
just would ask you uh to be careful with
your choice of words about elected
representatives okay
i am disappointed
sorry that representative
wallace knowing full well in the history
of the town that he lives in would try
to disenfranchise this vote the voters
this was more about trying to
disenfranchise the voters of danville's
people's choices and trying to
invalidate our votes because we turned
out in large numbers for these elections
and to tell us that our votes don't
count
and that they don't matter is another
form of voter suppression mr hanson
again uh i would ask you to not try to
assign motive to the
uh representatives just the facts please
okay
daniel webster uh
i have a quote from daniel webster's uh
procurer
where it's he says
it is sir the people's government made
for the people made by the people and
answerable to the people the people of
the united states have declared this
that this constitution
shall be supreme law
and i asked the committee not to move
this bill forward
um
one one more thing while i was i was
reading this um
it was brought forth that the road agent
um isn't elected and the selectmen have
have choice that's by law
um
tax collectors
what do you want town clerks
those those positions road agent
those positions um are by
by statue by rsa
they do have um
things that that the selectmen cannot
cannot do
cannot oversee
um
i i might add that just as the chief of
police
he's elected
we do not have selectmen do not have
oversea oversee his position either
so not every position because they're
elected
is overseen by the selectmen
um as your positions
um
you
you you
you we um
report
you
to the to the voters the voters are what
put you in you in the position
i think that
i don't know if i can answer any more
questions but i i would hope that this
that you people would understand that
this is just this is um
it has nothing
it's taken away the the voter's choice
and again citizen's petitions can be
changed
um as you know um
in a deliberative session
okay uh thank you for your testimony is
there anybody in the committee that has
a question from mr hanson
oh i'm sorry yes representative guthrie
yes thank you for coming and giving your
testimony
uh i i don't know if you
recall i asked a previous question
uh or
has to be clarified that this is not
taking away
the rights of the
voters of the town uh it'll still be
elected position we would not
be
presumptuous enough to take that away
my question to you is do you feel that
there should be any oversight at all
to the pursuit your position and why
would you
think one way or the other
so it would be taking away the rights of
the voters you'd be taking away the
right right of the voters to vote for
who they would like to be in that
position
i'm sorry i must have not have been
clear if i could mr chairman this bill
does not
do anything about whether it's an
elected or appointed position this bill
would uh continue
the elected position and the people in
danville would have an opportunity to
vote for whomever they wish
this is a question of whether or not
that position should have oversight and
my question is to you is do you think
there should be any oversight for this
position and if not why not
it would it would be taking away the
voters right who they put in there
because you have a board a board of
selectmen
could
and have
that's the reason why he became
elected
could remove somebody from that position
and put whoever they want in the
position that would take away the voters
choice
thank you for your answer
all right we have a question from
representatives
thank you mr chair my question is for
representative wallace
thanks for coming in and testifying
today i'm just wondering
i'm not really sure why this bill is
being put forward
right now can you give me a little
insight into that please
thank you representative uh thank you
for the question uh i will say asked and
answered we did uh that question was
asked earlier i'll repeat my answer
i'm so sorry i must have missed it but
thank you for repeating
yes uh you're entirely welcome
representative
why is this needed now because the town
electorate voted to make the animal
control officer position an elected
position but the warren article doing so
did not specify the lanes the ways and
means by which the position would be
governed
this bill simply sets forth a man by
which the position shall be administered
thank you
and next we have representatives davis
has a question
thank you mr chair um this is a question
also for representative wallace and
thank you for taking my question
representative
i have um kind of a three-part question
and it speaks to structure as opposed to
the specific uh
issues involved with this particular
bill and one is that
um as uh nate grays pointed out earlier
the section the rsa that the
this bill is proposed to amend
has to do with taking oaths of office
and
if this were to pass
the animal control officer would be the
only officer required to take an oath
that has this kind of a delineation of
responsibilities
and consequences
for responsibilities so
my question is why in this particular
rsa and not in another
and then my other question has to do
with the terms of selectmen
in this town versus the terms of the
animal control officer do they always
coincide or can they be different and
the reason i ask the question
is if a particular board of selectmen
has
prior has priorities and strategies in
in mind for a particular animal control
officer and their terms do not coincide
then does a new border selectmen have
the authority to impose new priorities
and strategies for that officer
thank you for the question
representative let me address the first
one uh
first of course um
when this was brought forward um i was
thinking about this from a uh an
existing position standpoint so that's
why i focused on the rsa 42.09
but
this is not my forte the municipal
county area that's where you folks come
in
and if it makes more sense to amend this
to uh have the governing statute be 41.2
i'm certainly on board with that would
be happy to make the amendment
um
to the second question um the warrant
article show has the aco be elected
annually
our boards of border select members have
different tenures um
and if there is an issue or a particular
matter that the uh the border sector
wishes to govern
well i don't know that that's an issue
presently because our current animal
control officer holds two positions in
town
one is aco and also a member of the
board of selectmen so
i i don't see what the problem would be
uh unless there's a conflict of one
supervising oneself but
given that set of circumstances i don't
think there should be a pushback from
the current aco she would be in fact
have a vote in her own supervision and
oversight would she not
no
okay
next i'm going to move on to
representative gallagher has a question
yes um so my questions for miss joe
hansen
so
um i'm wondering why
it is precisely that
danville is the only town that has an
elected animal control officer
in new hampshire um
like
um
you
what
what is it about
danville
that
causes it to have
issues with animal control that require
it to hold elections to choose between
people for this position
when other
other towns don't seem to feel that need
can you hear me
um
this position was created
because of small town politics
starting back in 2011.
um that's how the position got created
it's
it is
it i can't say it any other way it is
small town politics within danville
i don't believe any honestly the the
money that this this pays
nobody would
unless you were really passionate about
something
most people would just walk away from
the position and just you know and
whether it's appointed and just leave it
alone and go on um i'm very passionate
i've lived in this town over 33 years
um
yes currently i'm a selectman um and
honestly i became a selectman six years
ago because of this
i've been on different boards of the
town
i've been elected onto the budget
committee
i love the town i live in
do you have your hand up or is that an
old indication
i i i it looks like representative
has left the room for a moment i do not
have a hand up i just forgot to lower it
sorry okay uh
representative imaginary do we have
stacy over on the line
we
we did
yes we do
stacy is the last speaker she's going to
speak in support of the bill
good morning
chairman dolan members of the municipal
and county government committee my name
is stacy ober i am the legislative
analyst and community outreach in new
england for the american kennel club
and
uh american kennel club is a non-profit
we've been around for 135 years and
we're recognized as an expert in canine
health training breeding and responsible
dog ownership uh we have 22 non-profit
dog clubs in new hampshire
and when we saw this bill we understood
that the provisions would apply to only
one animal control officer in the state
and i had uh
i did reach out to the bill sponsor last
week i know you all had a very busy week
last week um so you do have a copy of my
written testimony i was looking at this
from the standpoint of giving you a
couple of examples where we believe
there would be value
in providing some consistency around
oversight and supervision for animal
control officers
and our reference was to rsa 466
section 1c
which
as everyone has acknowledged provides
great deal of discretion to the new
hampshire towns
as to how they will
provide these animal control services
in that language you'll see
uh it can be either an elected appointed
hired or subcontracted position and so
the testimony we submitted was really in
the spirit of saying we support
oversight and to please look at this
section of the law so that there would
be uniformity irrespective of what
capacity
um the animal control officer had been
employed or engaged
okay thank you any questions from his
over
seeing none
i'm gonna end the hearing
miss jim
there
are at least one more individual wish to
speak
um whether or not you're seeing them i
know the chief parsons does have his
hand up just send me a text to that okay
okay uh chief parsons are you on the
line
representative wallace um it's
can you just tell me chief parsons first
name wade wade
is he calling in or do you know if he's
zooming in
uh i believe he's called in or
he just sent me another text can you
hear me he has his hand up so he must be
zoomed in i imagine
the hand up is cody belanger and justine
merced those are the two hands up okay
well justine is the lieutenant in town
let's
oh there you go so maybe it's through
justine
i will hit aloud to talk and we'll try
that okay thank you thank you right uh
justine the floor is yours for right
ahead
hi this is justine merced are you able
to hear me now yes
hi thank you
so again i am the lieutenant in the town
of danville new hampshire and
i do support this bill and the reason
being is as far as i know we are the
only town in the state of new hampshire
that deals with an elected animal
control officer
i've been listening along the way here
and i do just want to stress again we're
not looking to change
anything about
this position being elected um i care a
lot about these residents in town as
well and it is really important to me
that these residents have
someone to rely on to hold this position
accountable
i can tell you
in my position
we receive animal control calls at the
pd that we have to forward to our
rockingham county sheriff's department
who handles dispatching
we also receive complaints
about our animal control officer we are
not able to do anything about those
types of complaints when we get them
because the animal control position is
not part of the police department as it
is in so many other towns in the state
of new hampshire
so when these complaints come our way we
direct them to the board of selectmen
quite frankly because we don't know
where else to send them
i've been present for some of these
complaints that go before the board of
selectmen and even there they pretty
much die because you know these these
residents are told that
they can't do anything about it so it's
not a matter of taking away
what the voters want in the sense of who
they want for
their elected animal control officer
i'm just looking for some type of
support that says should this animal
control officer not do what the town has
voted them to do that someone's going to
be there to support them to say okay
we're going to remove this person or
whatever take appropriate action against
this person so
um
we're not looking to get into any type
of personal politics or whatever was
insinuated earlier today it's just a
matter of holding this position
responsible just as with our road agent
i mean our town dealt with the same
thing with our road agent and our
current aco who's on that selectmen was
in support of oversight for that
position so i find it kind of odd that
there's a picking and choosing of what
positions that are elected
get oversight and just to touch upon
the chief of police that is a that is an
elected position as well however all
officers in the state of new hampshire
are held accountable by police standards
and training council so
my police chief is not able to just do
whatever he wants and
you know he's still held accountable
when calls don't get answered by the
animal control officer there's nobody to
to do anything about that when car calls
aren't handled handled appropriately
there's no one to be able to do anything
about that
and it's very frustrating for our police
department to hear that our residents
are so unhappy at times and and we can't
do anything about it
because they people think that this
position falls under the police
department and i just want to be clear
that it does not this this position is
separate this animal control position is
a different department than the police
department in the town of danville and i
know that it seems you know this is only
one town in all of the state but it is
the only town and i can tell you that it
we are heavily affected by this um she's
this position is not required to hold
any type of police certification um of
course they're able to
enforce some
violation level offenses they're not
allowed to go as far for misdemeanors to
prosecute these things um and i will
tell you
the person that is holding this position
right now sheila johansen
i know personally i don't trust her to
be part of my criminal investigations
because of history that she has shown
um herself
let me let me say that
i think that last comment would be
inappropriate so i would ask you to uh
just talk to the facts and not uh
okay and i apologize but
again that's really where we stand
as a police department as far as um
looking for someone to do something
because we can't we can't do anything to
hold this position accountable and it's
again it's frustrating we're hearing it
from our people of the town so i respect
their vote i respect want you know who
they choose it's just a matter of being
able to hold this position accountable
um when things aren't being done the
right way
thank you
let the record show that representative
piamonte
has
just been joined the committee in
we have the next question from
representative cleo
thank you mr chairman um i'm not sure
who to pose this question to if i would
be posing it to um
mercedes or um to representative wallace
but my question um
kind of straight up is based on what ms
merced uh commented about that if
there were complaints and there were
issues and that they could not they
currently cannot take any action i guess
my question would be what type of action
would they want to take short of um
eliminating an elected position
um
so i think that's basically what my
question is
i asked representative
wallace to
try to field that question
uh thank you representative klee for the
question uh it is it is my understanding
that at present time because there is no
uh
root source of the authority that the
animal control officer holds
there is no
potential for oversight or
um
[Music]
supervisory guidance or and or
discipline should the
conditions warrant and it's as simple as
that
um
so that's what we're hoping to get with
this uh measure is to at least be able
to have the position have some
accountability and oversight
um i'm not certain or i'm not privy to
all the details of what the nature of
the complaints are i don't wish to be
all i know is that we're having a
problem with this and it's it's already
cost the town plenty at this point in
time with the lawsuits multiple warrant
articles and uh you know and after all
that time has passed we get rid of the
position so now that court order is now
null and void because we did vote to
remove the elected acl position and have
since subsequently reinstated it so
that court order is
you know it's it's ancient history at
this point of time and has no effect so
here we are
thank you representative the last
question for this bill mr chairman i
have a quick follow-up just just a real
quick follow-up if that's okay we're
well behind schedule so please make it
quick
no that's okay i will i will pass up my
follow-up thank you so
okay the next question and last question
is from representative fan
thank you mr chairman this question is
for uh
ms merced
i guess my question here is
since this is an elected position
currently same as your town clerk is an
elected position
i would assume that just as if someone
complains about a town clerk
then
i i'm not quite sure why the animal
control officers being an elected
position
is any more difficult for the town than
the fact that the town clerk is an
elected position
can you unravel that for me please
so what i would say to that is um to the
i'm not familiar with any complaints
that go through the town clerk's office
i probably wouldn't be because it's it's
so
um different from the police department
the reason why i'm aware of these
complaints that are coming against the
animal control position is because
in my opinion based on these complaints
residents don't understand that the
animal control position is separate so
they're coming to the police department
looking for relief and then
we're not able to give them anything
what i would say to that is
um this
i guess this bill in general and the
idea behind this bill came from having a
problem um and that's why we're looking
for some help on
a statute end i don't know of any
problem that is arising from the town
clerk i'm not saying whether it's
appropriate inappropriate or whatnot
that's i don't have knowledge of the
town clerk what i do know is there is a
problem when it comes to the animal
control position so because there is a
problem
that's where this has come from
so i i'm not saying that it it's not
appropriate i have no idea but i know
that there's a problem with this animal
control position and that's why i'm here
to speak on that
okay thank you very much
this is a
complex issue and we've had a lot of
testimony to help us understand so thank
you all
uh
i have one more question represent
uh mr chair
it's uh
representative truleven
okay please make it fast
i will um
lieutenant merced thank you so much for
coming today and may i ask why would
someone who has a complaint not go
directly to the animal control officer
probably because that's who they have
the complaint with and if this person is
not answering their calls
they're looking for a person who's above
them just as if someone had a complaint
about me they're going to go to the
chief of police
because he's the one that's going to be
able to do something about that
thank you lieutenant merced
okay and with that thank you
representative
we're going to close the hearing on hp
431 thank you all for your testimony and
for your patience
mr
can you just give me the blue sheet sign
up please the previous notation on the
blue sheet was incorrect here's the
here is the correct numbers for this
particular bill
the hp 431
all those interested in the bill 21
signed up in support and five opposed
thank you
next we're going to open the hearing on
hb 439
this is uh regarding the powers of city
councils
and
local municipal governments
we have uh
several sponsors representative lasik on
the line
would you like to start
hello can you hear me
hello hello go ahead
okay thank you mr chairman um members of
the committee hb 439 attempts to amend
rsa 47 colon 17 to make it more
constitutionally appropriate
as many of you know new hampshire is not
a home rule state there have been three
attempts in modern history to amend the
constitution to give local authorities
more autonomy but all attempts have
failed the 1981 case gerard vs
allenstown upheld that towns and cities
derived their authority from the state
legislature
rsa4717 gives a laundry list of powers
to local authorities plenty in fact to
cover any issues i could foresee but the
problem i see specifically is with the
line that reads quote they may make any
other bylaws and regulations which may
seem for the well-being of the city
the term well-being is wildly unspecific
because of the broadness of the term i
do not believe that this could be
considered a specific authority granted
by the state legislature
what exactly qualifies as well-being
well in the town of enfield it
apparently includes picnicking in a
cemetery which is prohibited and let's
not forget about the town of newfields
which made an ordinance that resulted in
a reporter being fined for simply
reporting does the well-being of the
town include violating freedom of the
press
in laconia there is an ordinance that
goes above and beyond the state's
indecent exposure law to include a ban
of showing a female nipple in public
which practically prohibits public
breastfeeding i'm unaware of a state
statute that gives the local authority
the ability to prohibit public
breastfeeding
let's not forget that the proposed
curfew in nashua can anyone show proof
that curfews have done anything to curb
the spread of an infectious disease the
answer i can say with certainty is no
however does plenty to harm the
businesses and the liberty of the people
and i cannot find a statute that gives
the city the ability to arbitrarily
close all businesses at a certain hour
in conclusion the term well-being is far
too broad to be considered an authority
granted by the legislature
and i suggest striking the line in its
entirety from rsa4717
i'm attempting to make this law as
constitutional as possible if the people
of this state wish to be a home rule
state we could pass such an amendment
but as things stand right now well-being
is isn't an enumerated power granted by
the legislature should a local authority
find a need to add to the already
extensive list of powers granted by the
legislature i'm sure the legislature
would grant this authority but
well-being cannot be used as a catch-all
phrase
thank you
the questions for our representative
lasagna
seeing now let's move on to the next
speaker who is representative graves
from nhma
okay
very good should be all set mr chair
yeah i'm sorry i i gave you a title
barbie center
that's okay i appreciate the promotion
thank you um i am nate grays i'm
an attorney and lobbyist with the new
hampshire municipal association
we are opposed to this bill
um
the
phrase any other bylaws and regulations
which may seem for the well-being of the
city uh has been
in existence for
quite some time the earliest that i
could find any sort of reference to that
was uh
1846 so this has been a power given to
cities for
quite a long time now
and it's a manifestation of what's known
as the police power
that is
uh
that according to the supreme court
gives municipalities the authority to
promote such varied interests as public
health safety morals comfort
and the production of prosperity and the
general welfare and that comes from a
2019 new hampshire supreme court case
it's
i think it's really important to
recognize that this is a power that was
granted by the legislature to city
councils
to
make the bylaws that they need to make
to deal with local issues
um it's not
it's not broader than that there have
been a number of cases over the last
century and a half
about this power and how it operates
and it's clear that any
city
ordinance which would violate the
statutes or the new hampshire
constitution
is not valid the new hampshire supreme
court has said that numerous times
um
but it's this
this
is an important line in our say 4717
um because the legislature's recognized
that they simply can't list every
possible scenario that would come up
i'm certain that
everyone could think of a number of
different issues that could come up that
that are local that really could be
dealt with the local level
um and that would be
a real headache if every time one of
those came up the legislature to deal
with it we'd have very long hearings
where the legislature would have to
mediate between uh local
officials and try to determine what the
appropriate response is
um and it seems like
it would be more appropriate just to
leave the authority as it has been for
the last century and a half
and um
and allow this to be resolved to the
local level
um i
also want to note
that uh representative lasik
um listed some ordinances from from
towns as well as cities
i just want to point out that rc 4717
uh
roman 15 only applies to cities not to
town so those ordinances would be
enacted under a different statute i'm
happy to take any questions that any
members of the committee have questions
for mr
mr chair yes sir we have one from
senator major booty
thank you mr chair thank you uh mr grace
for taking my question
um
you pointed out yes it is the local
control
and
this ordinance in terms of changing the
public for public safety
i mean during a pandemic
and how often do we get pandemic so this
does this intrude on the local control
for the public safety
during what we are experiencing right
now to take that away
and this is my city and i feel safe that
we have this
uh ordinance to
keep us safe
would you allude to that please thank
you for the question so i i really can't
answer questions about specific
ordinances which may be uh in front of
courts at the moment because
part of what we do at nhma is provide
legal advice to
cities and towns um so
i i can't provide any advice that would
be
relative to
any ordinances which may be an issue
presently in the courts
um
but
you know the police powers
are
broad authority that
are given to government generally and
you know in this case they've been um
narrowed down to the local level
and really
it's important to keep in mind that
you know this this statute has a long
history and some of the things that have
been addressed have faded into the past
and hopefully
you know what we're talking about now
with the pandemic you know next year
this will be passed um and any sort of
issues that have come up as a result of
that um can be resolved appropriately
and we don't have to worry about that
but that's something that we've seen
over time that these issues come up um
local decisions have to be made
uh for to confront local problems um
they're not to the level that the
legislature needs to deal with them and
once they've dealt with that problem you
know time passes issues get resolved and
we can move forward
okay our next question is from
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you um mr
grace for taking this question as an
example i'd like to know this
if this were to pass
and there
occurred in a city
a situation where a swimming hole
became
poisoned
would that it would this enactment
prevent the city from saying the
populace could not use that swimming
place
um
i don't have the entirety of 47 17
memorized but i think that's a good
example of something that
wouldn't
be necessarily limited here
wouldn't necessarily be listed under
4717 in another
provision
[Music]
it would this removal of this power
would be a fundamental change to local
government
and it's something the local government
would have to come in front of the
legislature and say hey you know the
swimming pool is poisoned we need your
authority to close it or
um you know we have this issue with with
these two intersections of these two
roads or something that's so small
that it just really doesn't make sense
for the legislature to take up its time
to deal with
thank you
next uh question from representative
oh yes thank you mr chair and thank you
very much for taking my question
um
i just curious uh
where does it start
um
the legislation can be convened in 10
days
to roll on any any uh
problems and issues that come up
um within that ten day period
and some cities went beyond
the governor's emergency order
do you think that was appropriate
again i can't give an opinion as to any
any ordinances which may now be pending
before the courts um what i will say is
this new hampshire supreme court has
been very clear on
in a number of cases
where they've said
where they looked at
local ordinances and
they've said you know it's clear in the
statute and the statute
spells out
that
any ordinance which
goes against state law or the state
constitution wouldn't be valid
um these are really case-by-case basis
so i
it would be impossible to answer that
our next speaker
is going to be representative testerman
and she's on
i have a karen testerman which may be
also representative testerman and should
be all set to go
i'm sorry did i did i promote you
incorrectly
you did i am a city counselor in the
city of franklin my name is karen
testerman
and i happen to be married to
representative testerman so that may be
where the confusion is
um
thank you mr chairman for allowing me to
speak on this on behalf of this bill
i want to commend the um proponents of
this bill because they are trying to
make sure that we are
abiding by the constitution
in all of our legislation and going in
and actually finding areas in our
current legislation
where the
there are minor
um
changes that should be made that now uh
align us more in line with what it was
intended
in earlier in
last year i guess it was
in bert versus shirtless the supreme
court came back the u.s or the new
hampshire supreme court came in and said
that indeed no branch of state
government can lawfully perform any act
which violates the state constitution
and in
fact
removing the ambiguous language that
grants city councils the authority to
make laws and or ordinances that may
seem to be for the well-being of the
city is an appropriate uh sentence to
strike out and uh that's why i'm in
support of it in fact in my opinion
the
language
in
4717 should all be struck except for the
last
sentence to make it simple because
laws are supposed to be written so that
the common person can understand them
and going through all the legalese
before you get to the actual sentence is
very confusing to uh the common man and
so therefore i think that that it which
would be appropriate to amend this law
by striking everything except for the
last sentence that says no bylaw or
ordinance shall be repugnant to the
constitution of the laws of the state
and by and such bylaws and ordinances
shall take effect and be enforced from
the time they're in limited without the
sanction or confirmation of any other
authority whatever
i am
asked that you would uh pass this bill
as ought to pass and i'd be happy to
take any questions i have also emailed
uh the committee
my statement
thank you for
uh doing that email that makes it much
easier for us to create the uh
the build file so at this point i'm
gonna ask if there are are there any
members of the of the committee that
have questions for council person
testimony
yes that's our representative
thank you mr chairman so uh
councilman testament karen do you know
this whole
slack sentence seems to hit john the
question the single definition of
well-being
do you know what rsa what that defines
the word well-being and what that means
uh i do not and i and therefore i think
that there are times when
yes there are individual situations but
that is uh something that i think that
we have the ability
as elected persons to be able to address
on an individual basis
rather than
putting it into the law books
follow yes go ahead
so it was roger the cdc defines
well-being as there's no consensus
around a single definition of well-being
but the general agreement that at a
minimum well-being includes the presence
of positive emotions and moods
uh contentedness happiness the absence
of negative emotions does that sound
something that a city should try to
govern through
ordinance
no
thank you
thank you um next i'm sorry we have a
question from committee member
representative
thank you mr chair
um
i guess this is a question for um
councilwoman testerman
in rsa 4717
the um the law
governs the sale or barter of junk
if i have an issue with the way the word
junk is defined
how does this law help me
and why
are you not proposing to change that
piece of subjectivity
as opposed to the one that you have
proposed changing
if you will um
i i'm sorry was that in another section
of the law
actually in the same section
it is hold on just a second it's line
13.
uh wait a second i don't have the
legislation right in front of me well
let me read it to you
amongst the things that cities can
regulate
butchers petty grocers hucksters
peddlers hawkers and common viddlers
dealers in and keepers of shops for the
purchase sale or barto of junk
and then it goes on from there
and
representative thank you for the
question and that is why i suggested
that all of the language prior to the
last sentence in that
law be struck i think it would be
well
a good measure of the um
committee to go ahead and amend this
bill and strike out everything
beforehand simply because
people have put whoever put this bill
together in the or this language
together in the first place was trying
to
imagine all the possibilities and
you know somebody else can come by
and have
another idea that is not listed in there
for or in con conflict with it and
therefore you're you're
causing conflict that should be
addressed on an uh
issue by issue situation
up mr chair please yes please go ahead
then then why do we not have that
amended bill before us
why why are we only looking at this one
line if if in your uh judgment it would
be preferable to strike everything prior
to that line why is that we're just
considering this today
i uh thank you for the question but i
did not write the uh um the lsr or
the language of the bill
i'm just saying that as a test
as testifying on this bill
uh as a city councilor that that i i
would recommend that that's what be done
thank you very much okay uh before i go
to the next speaker which will be
representative
let me go back
to representative andrew for a second
question
thank you mr chair uh part of my
question was asked by my colleague just
before who spoke and i am just looking
at this was over a period of time that
was uh this rsa was put into place
and to strike
years of work from the legislation
and recommending
amending to
almost clean slate seems to me
this overturning a whole
work of
legislation am i representing
can you form that in the form of a
question yes so to when uh represent and
when
previous uh testimony her
miss
counselor testament
said strike everything out
so is she test are you testifying to
this current
bill that we have or are you
testifying
to a bill that is not here you're
amending i'm a little confused as to
where you're coming from
thank you for the question
um yes i am
testifying in favor of the current bill
that is in front of you i am merely
recommending that maybe you might want
to also
amend this bill
as it is in committee
to adjust it and i don't know what the
proper process is for that that is up to
you as the committee members thank you
very much for your question
okay and the next question is from
representative matthew murray
thank you mr chair and uh thank you
councilwoman testerman for taking my
question although i think my question
based on your testimony may be best
for nate graves from nhma
i'm reading article 1 of the
new hampshire constitution
and it says all men are born equally
free and independent therefore all
government of rights originates from the
people is founded in consent and
instituted for
the general good
is the general good defined
uh i do not believe so but i do think
and thank you very much for your
question i do believe that
according to our constitution
that law should not be made except by
the approval of the people
and so
it is the consent of the govern that
should be allowed and in fact if you
really go through the constitution it
says the general court should only
uh be meeting
to address
the concerns of the state or the
citizens
and so that does not mean that you
should be meeting every six months
for a full time to be introducing a lot
of legislation for us to
mitigate as citizens
thank you
our next speaker is going to be
representative oregon
who
wants to speak in opposition
mr chair i have been looking for
representative horrigan uh since we
started and unfortunately i do not see
him on the uh on the zoom call either by
name or by phone that i can identify
that's that's over
i believe uh councilman mcnamara from
lebanon who wants to speak in the
opposition of the bill
good to go
right
can you hear me
yes you're looking fine
thank you
good morning
my name is tim mcnamara and i'm
currently serving as the mayor of the
city of lebanon
in your written submittals you'll find a
letter prepared by me
and signed by 12 of the 13 mayors of new
hampshire cities
my intent in testifying this morning is
simply to amplify on the points made in
our joint letter
hb 439
seeks to modify the language of rsa 47
colon 17
to remove the ability of cities to enact
ordinances
which are not specifically identified in
the statute but are
in the words of the statute and i quote
not repugnant to the new hampshire
constitution
or to the laws of the state
now while the list of permissible
ordinances found in rsa 4717 is
exhaustive
many of the topics appear to date from
the 19th or possibly the early 20th
century
and are by no means inclusive of the
types of ordinances which are currently
on the books
of many of our new hampshire cities
today
for example
there is no specific mention in the rsa
of ordinances relating to zoning
or to sewers
or to parking or even to dog
registrations
topics which are commonly addressed in
many local laws
it is vitally important
that cities have the ability to
expeditiously react to evolving
situations
by enacting ordinances
to protect public health and safety
and and to enhance and advance
the public interest
this is precisely the reason that rsa 47
colon 17
includes the catch-all phrase that
cities may make other bylaws and
regulations which may seem for the
well-being of the city
i can assure you
that in making these other bylaws and
regulations
we who represent the citizens of our
city are all what cities are always
mindful that such regulations must be in
conformance
with our state constitution laws
eliminating our discretionary ability to
rapidly enact ordinances which we deem
to be in the best interest of our
citizens
is both unnecessary
and unwise
in closing on behalf of the city of
lebanon and the other 11 signatories to
our letter
i respectfully request that the
committee find
h hb 439 as an expedient to legislate
thank you for your time
thank you mayor i have a question
from representative cleve mayor mcnamara
thank you very much um mr chairman and
thank you uh mayor mcnamara for taking
my question
um i will be honest with you i'm an
alderman also in uh in the city of
nashua um
and
the when the curfew
law came up or the request we defeated
it very handily but um putting that
aside if we were to pass something like
that and um
and and i assume you you have the same
issue in your city would the courts not
um have the right to uh step in either
through a um independent um
citizen or even a legislator to come in
and to sue the city have you experienced
anything like that
i'm certainly not a lawyer or legal
expert but i'm very confident that the
courts would have the ability to step in
okay thank you very much for taking my
question
and we have a question
another question from
foodie
thank you mr s
chair thank you
uh mayor mcnamara for taking my question
um
if this bill was uh in uh
law right now
how would it hamper
mayors like you in the different cities
do a responding
i'm sorry i didn't catch the end of your
question representative
you said how would it hamper us in and i
didn't catch the end of it yeah how
would it have hampered you to uh
as a mayor to
enact or
safeguard the safety of the citizens
well i'll give you a specific example um
relating to the pandemic so
we had not considered a mass coordinates
and
we were reached out to um by
at least one prominent local small
business owner
who said that they were having a lot of
trouble
uh with voluntary compliance with a mask
order that that they had enacted for
their business
and that they felt that it was not being
um
uniformly um
administered over the entire city so we
were able to act very rapidly
and enact what we felt was a very
reasonable
uh mass coordinates which is still in
effect
we had only minimal
negative feedback to that i think it has
been very positive
in keeping the incidence of covert 19
down in the city of lebanon
i have my doubts that we would have been
able to do that
quickly if we had to do it through the
legislature and get it into
into the rsas so
it would hamper us
uh in what we call emerging situations
now
these are not ordinances that last
forever they are ordinances that last
for the period of time that we deem them
to be necessary
and we certainly try not to have more
ordinances on the books than we need so
i believe that
thank you
and uh
next question is
representative uh
has a question
thank you mr chairman
um
uh mayor uh
i was wondering if you could
give us an example of what the timeline
and procedure would be like
if in fact this ordinance
this
bill
passed through the legislature and the
governor signed it what would be the
procedure
for adding an ordinance
at the city level
well i would imagine that we would need
to get one of our you're talking about
if we required state action to be able
to enact an ordinance
if you
yes if you needed state action in order
to pass an ordinance certainly so
we would go through one or more of our
representatives
we would ask that representative to
prepare
a bill for passage
they would need to take it before
presumably this committee
if it was deemed expedient to legislate
then through
the house of representatives and so i
could envision certainly several months
from the time we
came up with the idea for an ordinance
to the time it was potentially enacted
the next
question is from representative tripp
here in
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
uh
it seems that
if this was to be removed from the law
what would the effect
be on
ordinances are existing already would
they suddenly become uh
unlawful and disappear
that's a great question and i and i
don't have an answer to it because i
don't know if it would cause all
existing ordinances
with uh with other than the ones that
are currently listed there
to
be invalid i don't know it might our
zoning ordinance might disappear our
sewer ordinance might disappear i don't
know the answer to that
okay thank you um
we have
one more question from our designer
reporter
[Music]
thank you mr chair and thank you mayor
um for taking my question
um
i'm listening to all this i live in a
town it's a little different than a city
but i know that this committee has had
to listen to a lot of bills to solve
problems for an individual community in
fact we just listened to one this
morning that took an hour
in your opinion if you needed to get
authority
from the legislature before you passed a
local
ordinance to deal with a local specific
problem that's happening
would you see a lot of laws being
enacted do you think that our
one-size-fit-all
laws for all the states cities um yes i
do
yes i do we all have our own individual
problems
we certainly have a lot of common
problems but there are things that come
up in one municipality that may not come
up in another and i do see a lot of
potential for a lot of one-size-fits-all
um bills and a very exhaustive list by
the time you
took care of everything that need to be
taken care of
thank you
yeah questions from
the committee from
representative theomonte
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
being at dylan will state
you mentioned the
pandemic as an example but outside of
that
would this apply to anything you wanted
to do
i think that's what the
bill is getting at
can you respond to that
i'll certainly try i mean
i think that there is a possibility
that um
a municipality
could come up with an ordinance i would
hope we did not do it in lebanon but
someone might
that in fact was repugnant to the new
hampshire constitution the laws of the
state in that case there is a
legal remedy
to
overturn that ordinance so i think the
remedies are there to fix a problem if a
problem occurs
uh i am
doubtful that this will happen that that
would happen very often
okay uh next question is from
representative gallagher
so
this is a follow-up to representative
porter's question so
if we do see an increase in
one-size-fits-all
legislation for
um
relating to local issues for
municipalities
which committee
would you foresee those coming before
like would it be this one the municipal
and county government committee in other
words are we going to be creating a lot
more work for ourselves by
passing this bill
i would imagine that you folks would be
the first stop and i would see the
potential for a lot of discussions
similar to the one you just had on hp i
think was 431
which was very very specific and i could
see that happening dozens of times
over the course of a year
thank you
i think our last
person to testify is going to be
nancy vaughn from the american heart
association
mr bill
yes good morning can you hear me you're
fine
okay well um for the record um i am
nancy vaughn government relations
director for the american heart
association here in new hampshire and i
want to thank you
for this opportunity to comment in
opposition to house bill 439
for many of the reasons that you've
already heard so i'll try to be brief on
my testimony
why the american heart association is
here today is we do advocate for public
policies
both at the state level community level
federal level to create environments
where people can easily make healthy
choices including active lifestyles
access to nutritious foods and living
tobacco-free
we want everyone to benefit from smart
and effective policies that promote
health and safety as well as civic
engagement
what we don't want to see is for states
to block local governments from passing
laws that make sense to
local communities
it can hurt people where the need is
greatest limiting local decision making
usually leaves communities stuck in that
one-size-fits-all rule that doesn't
always make sense for every community
local governments are uniquely
positioned to meet the needs of the
people
in their communities they are more
connected to residents and more
accountable to them
local residents and local leaders want
what's best for their communities they
know how to solve local problems because
they see them up close
and when local communities come up with
a solution to their challenges and put
them
together come together to put them in
practice
state government should be there to help
them improve those and not necessarily
strike them down
i won't go into a lot of description
because this is in my written testimony
but one example that came to mind when i
saw this bill is the impact that it
could have on local policies
which are designed
designed roadways that are safe for all
users so there's several communities in
new hampshire that have what's called
complete streets or walkable communities
and these are roadways that have
features and designs that the local
communities do
to make them safer
for both pedestrians and for even
motorists
and it also is is something that can
also benefit businesses by bringing foot
traffic
to those local businesses so in
conclusion
i urge you to vote in expedient to
legislate in house bill 49
that
states should build
the foundation for local communities
and basic protections so everyone's
treated fairly local government should
then have the ability to strengthen
those protections based upon what they
know about their communities
and it's much more effective when state
and local governments can coordinate and
work in solidarity to localize build
upon and strengthen minimum state
standards to meet those unique needs of
communities
so again i did submit written testimony
and i really really hope that
we can work together on
meaningful and effective policies
thank you for your testimony and thank
you again for submitting in writing it
makes it much easier for us
so uh hearing uh no further requests the
question
are there any members of the public that
are locked on uh wish to wait
just by the way uh by virtue of the blue
sheet of those who are signing in on the
bill
there were 156 that support this
legislation and 47 opposed
okay seeing no additional testimony
going to conclude the hearing
representative um i'm sorry chairman um
i do see cody belanger has his hand up
and i'm not sure if that's the state
representative but um he's has his hand
up and would like to speak
okay uh i'm sorry we'll hear from
representatives
good evening members of the excuse me
good morning members of the committee
can you hear me okay yes
thank you um for the record i i just
want to point out i did have my hand up
before you close the uh
the session on the previous bill as well
that i was going to testify and
unfortunately was not noticed so um just
want to advise to keep your eyes open
for that and i mean no disrespect of
that advisement
um
so
with that i would like to um thank you
mr chair and the honorable members of
the committee for hearing my testimony
today on this bill
my name is representative cody belanger
i represent the town of epping which is
rockingham district 9 where i am also a
selectman
i'm here today to ask you to support
this bill
some cities and towns have gone above
and beyond the governor's executive
orders based on perhaps party
affiliation emotion and maybe not even
facts
for
example one of the things that my town
did
was
do an ordinance that passed
um that would require the people of the
town to wear a mask coming into town
hall but did not require
people who worked inside town hall to
wear a mask i was the sole dissenting
vote against that
as the member from sandown alluded to
when does this stop
what this build does is change the line
excuse me
for quote
for the well-being
unquote which appears and can be
transcribed as a catch-all of authority
for local authorities to do as they wish
let's take the town of newfields for
example as the member from merrimack who
is the prime sponsor on this bill
mentioned
this helped allow a town to pass an
unconstitutional mandate from peaceful
protesting whether you agree where the
protesting took place or not
it further
it took it further excuse me and ended
up finding a reporter
and was a direct attack on the first
amendment
that this concludes my testimony i asked
the committee to pass this bill otp so
that situations like the town of
newfield don't continue to arise
thank you for your testimony uh
representative
i apologize for not noticing you before
i have a uh
electronic device that tells me who uh
to speak and uh europe it did not
indicate
that this bill will last build so it may
be a technology limitation
with the system we're using that but i
apologize for that
uh
is there anybody from the committee that
was
asked a question of representative
my screen doesn't indicate anybody is
that correct
i did there are no hands up in attendee
no hands up in attendees but i do see
representative stavis has her hand
raised
okay for some reason my device is stuck
and i can't see that so representatives
go right ahead
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative belanger i just have a
question for you
if this
law as currently written
included a provision that no town no
city council
could pass a mask mandate would it be
okay with you
this build to me has nothing to do with
any mask mandate it's just pertaining to
situations such as new fields um
and
any potential unconstitutional
adjustments to that as well follow up
please mr chair yes go ahead you did
mention a mask mandate i believe in your
town pertaining to the city hall
yes thank you
okay no further questions i'm going to
close testimony on
hp 439
thank you
[Music]
at this point i'm going to open uh
testimonial house bill 463 which is
referring to
how the town clerk is appointed
in that community
in the
community of warren
so uh
see we have
ready to testify we have uh
jill hatch an elected official is that
are you a select person
no good morning i'm i'm
can you hear me okay first oh yeah thank
you
okay thank you actually i'm
representative william hatch
i represent the uh wonderful towns of
gorham and shelburne i'm district six in
coast county
and um
i and thank you mr chair and honourable
members for hearing me this morning
um
uh my legislative history this is i
think uh my eighth or ninth term in the
past i've served as vice chair ways and
means vice chair finance division one uh
last time i was chair of jail car also
still serve on dell car and i am
currently ranking member of division one
in finance
um before you i've introduced house bill
and that's to allow the selectmen
to appoint the town clerk as opposed to
it being a constitutional office or
elected office i submitted this bill at
the request of the selectmen
and with you also is our very capable
town clerk denise valley delhi and
she'll speak to the uh where with all of
this bill and why it was introduced
and thank you mr chair and honorable
committee any questions for uh
representative hatch thank you mr chair
if i may um
mrs valley can is certainly capable of
answering any questions uh because of
your overtime i'm now double um
doing two meetings at once and it's not
working well for me so i'll actually ask
questions to um
uh our town manager miss valley she can
certainly answer any um questions that
you may have before you thank you mr
chair and thank you committee
miss valley are you on the line with us
i am
can you hear me yes
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee
um i am town manager not town clerk
because um representative hatch
initially stated so
um very quickly the gorham board of
selectmen is respectfully requesting
that they be given the authority to
appoint the town clerk tax collector
currently we have one person filling
both positions along with a deputy the
position is currently staffed by a
full-time person who's been with us for
10 plus years and a deputy is the former
full-time clerk tax collector who was
with the town for more than 35 years
our full-time town clerk is expected to
retire within the next couple of years
but may do so sooner and our deputy
wishes to retire within a few months
the full-time position pays over fifty
thousand dollars with benefits there is
no one that we know of in gorham who is
qualified and is willing to be elected
to the position we do know of at least a
couple of financially skilled people who
would take the position if they were to
be appointed ingorum the town clerk tax
collector is responsible for collecting
just over four million dollars in
revenues including over six hundred and
forty thousand in motor vehicle
registrations the town recently updated
its software that provides for the
assessment data to be exported to a
collect pro system which then generates
the property tax bills this system is
very complicated and takes quite some
time to master
for someone who is not very good at
computer programs to attempt this would
be disastrous
the clerk's side of the position keeps
the registered roles and election
documents in the same office as the tax
collector
the town long ago determined that the
only way to get someone to competently
manage both roles was to make a combined
position and to compensate that person
accordingly
we fear a situation where we are
statutorily required to hand over these
duties to someone who is unqualified but
has been elected based on their
popularity or because the position is
uncontested
the board wishes to appoint a qualified
applicant that has the relevant
background financial training and the
required skills and experience necessary
to adequately perform the duties of the
town clerk tax collector decision
we feel that this position is of vital
importance and that it should be filled
with the most skilled and experienced
applicant possible
thank you uh representative porter has
her hand up to ask a question
thank you mr chair and thank you miss
valley for taking my question
i think at the beginning of your
testimony
you said you knew no one that was
qualified that was willing to run
but that they were qualified people who
might serve
if they were appointed can you explain
that a little bit further to me this
people you know who could do the job but
they don't want to put their name on the
ballot is that what you're saying
i am saying that um they they would like
to be appointed so that they are assured
that the position is theirs um longer
than just a two-year term
um
and
the
um current town clerk does not mind the
fact that she is appointed she's been
here for 10 years and she's fine with
that but we are really worried about a
person running that does not have the
financial
skills and background that would just
win this
you know win an elected position
um
just based on the fact that they want to
you know give it a try and they don't
really have the skills to do it and it's
a very important
vital position to the town you're
dealing with a lot of money and we don't
want that to happen
can i have a follow-up mr chair yeah
follow up
and so and so that
you know usually in a situation like
that where there's someone who doesn't
have the background there's a deputy
that works with them that actually is
the one that coaches the clerk and makes
sure that everything is
the way it should be but you said your
deputy is also retiring
that's correct she actually wanted to
retire last december and has stayed on
so if the could you do you appoint your
deputies or do they get elected
the deputy is appointed
thank you
and the next question is from
representative mitchell on the committee
thank you mr chairman
um
thank you uh
miss
uh ms valley for
being here to answer our questions
if
this becomes a an appointed position
and you're unable to find somebody
who is a resident of gorham would
because it is an appointed position
would you be able to go outside of the
town
to find a qualified person
that is one consideration right now our
other
appointed positions in town we are able
to appoint from outside of the town i do
know that one of the people that is
interested in the appointed position is
a gorham resident
i'm sorry
yes
follow-up is uh
i i understand that the elected position
is
is town clerk tax collector not sure if
if they're two separate positions
but the assistant
is that person selected by the board or
the elected official
that person is typically right now
selected
by the town clerk but with the approval
of the board of selectmen she usually
makes sure that they're fine with
whoever she's appointing
thank you
you're welcome next question is from
representative magic booty
thank you mr chase thank you miss uh
well for taking my question so changing
this to
appointed position would this help with
frequent turnover
of election every two years especially
performing an important task as stack
collection which is the revenue
for the town would this help
make a stability
and continuity
i do feel that this would make a big
difference as far as having someone in
the position for a long longer amount of
time
okay uh
next question is from representative
chile
uh thank you very much mr chair and
thank you ms valley uh for coming today
and
testifying so concisely i've just two
quick questions you're welcome i have
two quick questions um what's the
population of the town of gorham
we are just under 3 000 people okay and
my second question is i heard you say
earlier in your testimony that the town
clerk who's currently there was
appointed how did that happen
no
um i was saying that the um deputy
was appointed the town clerk ran for
election
and so the town clerk has run
i'm sorry every two years for election
she has okay thank you so much
and the next question is from
representative
at the
lobby here
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking the question
um i i didn't know if i caught it
correctly but you said you have a person
in town that's afraid to go on the
ballot that's qualified
that true
yes and i i wouldn't say that she's
afraid i would say that she wants to
have the position if it's an appointed
position she does not want to
um have to run for election and then
worry about running every two years
after that
yes i'm sorry
the
question of stability came up
on this have you had any problem in the
past with stability i i thought i heard
you had
a president that's been there for years
uh we are worried um about stability in
the event that someone runs that does
not have the qualifications needed to do
this position and that's where the
instability would come in
next we have testimony from kelly
roberts from deerfield who wants to
speak in opposition
hello can you hear me
yeah where are you going we're right in
here
hi my name is kelly roberts
i'm a lifelong resident of deerfield new
hampshire i am also deerfield's elected
town clerk tax collector
i was first elected in march 2018 and
i'm up for re-election this year
prior to being elected counselor i
served as the deputy town clerk tax
collector for almost 11 years
i have spent over a decade
working for an office that directly
serves the voters and the public
i've eminently opposed hb 463 which
seeks to turn the gorham town clerk tax
collector's office from an elected
position to an appointed position
i ask that everyone here oppose this
bill this is a bad bill and i'll explain
why
the town clerk is a local election
official that administers town state and
federal elections within their
communities
this fact alone is reason enough to
always keep the clerk an elected
position
an elected official such as the clerk
can never be perceived by the voters and
the public
that they serve as being influenced by
any board any committee or any agenda
purity of elections and faith in the
process is integral for democracy
the community sees the clerk as part of
this democratic process
the clerk is someone voters and
residents are comfortable talking with
outside of the board of selectmen
clerks provide a neutral space for
residents and voters to conduct their
transactions
if the clerk is placed under the board's
direct supervision that neutrality and
autonomy is gone
that public trust is not as strong
the perception of the clerk serving the
public first and foremost is replaced
with the notion that the clerk serves
the board of selectmen's mission
and the public second
the quality of service is diminished
the clerk serves the public faithfully
and impartially the role of the clerk is
to be autonomous and accountable to the
public
the funda this fundamental principle
allows the clerk to perform their duties
with integrity and transparency
the clerk is not an arm of the board of
selectmen or the governing body they are
a stand alone elected leader in the
community
they do not work for the border
selectmen rather they work with the
board of selectmen and vice versa
a clerk does not work for a town manager
or a town administrator
rather they work with them to meet the
town's needs
an elected clerk is more service
oriented as they directly serve the
public doing transactions
the more the board of selectmen's role
in the day-to-day transactions is a
conflict of interest
and a potential violation of state and
federal privacy laws
they have no business supervising them
and they have no good reason to be privy
to the transactions they conduct
those who support appointing a town
clerk argue that they can hire a more
qualified person for the job
this simply is not true and a weak
argument
the truth is there is no college degree
to become a town clerk
to become a clerk you must learn from
other clerks
and state agencies and clerks
associations that you work with peery
you don't learn to be a clerk from the
select board when a new clerk is elected
they attend clerk trainings and network
with other clerks
the new hampshire city and town clerks
association offers training and a
certification program
those who support appointing a clerk
suggest that it makes the position less
about
makes it less about a popularity contest
and more about the qualifications
this is not the case a person who runs
for clerk is someone who accepts public
life and is willingly choosing to serve
their positions through the electoral
process
it's not a popularity contest it's an
election process
when you remove an elected position
you are removing the opportunity for the
community to vote who they want
you are literally taking
away a vote from the people
new hampshire has a strong history of
amazing clerks it is a tight-knit group
we stick together and we learn from each
other if clerks became appointed they
may not be as respected from their clerk
colleagues who value the democratic
process
people have actually said to me that
they feel bad that i have to re-run for
office every three years
while i'm flattered that they're
concerned for my future i also recognize
that there needs to be an awareness
raising in new hampshire that clerks are
not like other departments or other
elected officials we are a unique hybrid
most of what we do is based in statute
as process related and is fundamentally
rooted in the democratic
process
there really is nothing that the board
needs to supervise
if a board is worried that nobody will
run for clerk they shouldn't because
there will always be someone to step up
to the plate
a point of clarification there are some
positions within municipal government
that may be better suited as an
appointed position
there are valid arguments that support
this however this does not apply to the
clerk the clerk position is an entirely
different animal
a special hybrid of statutory roles and
duties
some terms towns have a separate town
clerk and a separate tax collector's
office
there are provisions under the law to
allow tax collectors to be appointed
some towns have combined the two
positions making the town clerk tax
director's office one office this is
common in many towns
in combined offices the town clerk is
both the town clerk and the tax
collector and it has to be an elected
office because of the town clerk's
duties and responsibilities
there are so many reasons why this is a
bad bill i did reach out to the clerk in
gorham and she opposes this bill
this is not the direction we want new
hampshire to go in
the clerk is a stand-alone leader within
a community for a good reason
separation of duties safeguards against
abuse of power and provides balance
while maintaining a positive public
perception
this is not a partisan issue this is a
fundamental issue of the local
democratic process
james madison known as the father of the
constitution
is famously quoted as saying
if men were angels no government would
be necessary end quote but men are not
angels and thus political powers even at
the municipal level
must be separated and balanced
thank you for letting me speak
thank you mr roberts
thank you mr chair for taking my
question thank you for taking my
question
uh
actually there's
several questions but i can maybe just
uh sum it up
uh
it appears that uh
the tax
the clerk tax collectivisation is common
in uh
your area
it appears that the
selectmen are concerned
with the
tax collector
uh
position being filled by
someone's
skill is necessary
but it also appears
that uh
in gorham
the clerk isn't actually doing the tax
collective duties he has uh
he or she has an assistant
so
it doesn't
seem to
the uh
parent why
the clerk has to
be
appointed
when they're not doing the tax
collective duties
is that
the town clerk tax collector is one
position in gorham
so both the town clerk tax collector and
the deputy town clerk tax collector
are doing both town clerk and tax
collector duties
okay i have uh
two other hands rates
that i want to make sure that we're
pursuing questions uh
before we go on traditional testimony so
david scanlan do you have a
question or do you want to offer
additional testimony
thank you mr chairman i'd like to offer
daniel healey do you have a question or
do you want to offer additional testing
mr chairman this is david scanlan i'd
like to offer additional testimony right
i understand that it's just stand-up but
i
want
questions first
this is this is daniel i am the dairy
town clerk and i too would like to offer
additional testimony all right before we
go to you to
gentlemen because i believe she has a
to youtube
question
no mr chair i put my hand down my
question was answered by someone else
okay then we're going to go to
mr stanley for additional testimonies
thank you mr chairman my name is david
scanlan i'm the deputy secretary of
state
uh and as been our
practice in similar bills in the past we
vigorously oppose
uh an attempt to make a town clerk
appointed um i think that clerk roberts
did a fantastic job in explaining the
issues involved
so i'm not going to repeat that
testimony
except to say
that that we interact this office
interacts with clerks in two main areas
elections and in vital records
uh
elections uh is in new hampshire is
built on checks and balances through the
entire process and the elections
whether they're local state or federal
are conducted at the local level
and the clerks
along with moderators and supervisors of
the checklist are very integral to that
process
and it is critically important that they
maintain entertainment in that process
that they don't have to answer to
somebody
uh that
may potentially try and impact decisions
that they make in a critical role of
making sure that our elections are free
and fair and full of integrity
so i would simply echo clerk robert's
comments in that respect
vital records is also another area
where we deal with the clerks clerks are
tasked with maintaining
the privacy of citizens in your town in
terms of data that they have to report
related to
births deaths marriages divorces
divorces
adoptions and they have access to all of
that information
under law excuse me they have to keep
private and confidential
they should not be placed in a situation
where somebody that that has their thumb
on them through some supervisory uh
role um
uh you know can can manipulate that
person and uh so obviously
that's an area of concern that we have
and then the final thing that i would
like to say just to
reinforce what clerk robert said
was that the clerks have an incredible
training and certification process it is
very involved i would equate it with
taking graduate courses uh
you know at college uh they are very
committed to that uh you know we
participate in those as instructors
and i can tell you that the clerks
without exception in new hampshire take
that
process and their role very seriously
so i would
just
start off where i began and say that we
oppose this legislation and i would be
happy to answer any questions
thank you uh mr scanlon i believe uh
representative salas has a question
yes uh thank you mr scanlon for taking
my uh
question i'm particularly interested in
the
with respect to elections
i would like to know the relationship
between
the town clerk the
uh supervisor of the checklist
and the moderator
is there a connection a reporting
responsibility to for those three people
does the checklist supervisor
who does the checklist supervisor report
to
they are all
independent entities but they have to
work together as a team they all have
very distinct roles uh that are
described
in the statutes
uh the supervisors of the checklist are
responsible for voter registrations they
are the only
elected body in the state that can put
names on the voter checklist
or take names off the voter checklist
the secretary of state does not have
that authority that role as supervisors
of the checklist
the moderator is the
is the chief election official uh on the
day of the election
and has uh significant responsibilities
in terms of making sure that the polling
place
runs smoothly
on the day of the election that person
is
the general the top person
in terms of
deciding how the processes work
under the confines of the statute and
then the clerk
has duties
that are well beyond election day
because they are responsible for
the ballots
if it's a local election the clerk is
responsible for designing and printing
the ballots if it's a state election
and local elections the clerk is
responsible for making sure that the
absentee ballot
request forms are received and processed
and that the voters
receive their ballots
they're responsible for
keeping track of the ballots leading up
to the election making sure that they
get delivered to the polling place and
then is responsible for their safe
keeping
after the election is over
all of those entities this moderator the
supervisors and the clerks have a role
in recounts where they all
make up the board of recount along with
the
selectmen
and um
you know it is uh it's a well-oiled
machine in new hampshire
if in almost every instance
uh these these uh different elected
election officials just work incredibly
well together
and that's borne out by the fact that
new hampshire
compared to the rest of the country has
very smooth elections
a question from uh representative plea
here
uh thank you mr chair and um thank you
uh mr scanlon
uh mike my question to you is
on a city level the city clerks
do i believe all of those duties that
you had said maybe there was something
that i missed
why
why does it work okay in the city and
not in the towns and i know government
is completely different from one to the
other but um they have the same
responsibilities of of bringing the
ballots etc to
to making sure that the checklist is
done
as a matter of fact i know that you
stole our previous city clerk
to work within your organization and we
miss her dearly but we do love our
current one um here in nashua
um can you explain why
it's it's not as an issue for our city
clerk to not be elected versus a town
clerk yes thank you for that question
representative klee um so in the cities
the city clerk is the chief election
official in the city
and the city clerk is responsible for
the uniform practices and training and
everything that takes place
for
elections that are held in the city
whether they're local state or federal
however every city has a ward or wards
depending on its size
and each of those words has an elected
board of selectmen an elected moderator
and elected uh board clerk
and those are the individuals that are
responsible for
conducting the uh the elections
in the ward under the statutes
there is no distinction really that is
made between
a town
or a city ward in terms of how the
election process is run
thank you follow up follow up mr chair
quickly please
okay i will um
so basically what you're saying is that
the difference is the elections but the
other duties that were described as far
as i think someone talked about marriage
license
et cetera et cetera those are still done
by our city clerk without an elected
official is that correct or i'm mistaken
on that
oh you're correct and and the clerk has
many responsibilities to go well beyond
elections and and vital records
and uh you know obviously they you know
they deal with voter motor vehicle
registrations dog licenses
um those are areas the secretary of
state does not get involved in but the
clerk does have those responsibilities
thank you i want to move now on to our
last speaker uh mr daniel bailey please
identify yourself where you're from and
whether you support and oppose
daniel healey i'm the derry town clerk
i'm representing the new hampshire
clerks association and our association
is opposed to this bill
um we're opposed for the reasons that
clerk roberts mentioned everything that
she said in her testimony is exactly how
her association feels
um representative tripp brought up a
comment on the combined office
a town can vote to split the office of
town clerk and tax collector after they
have voted to combine it
so if gorham believes that they're going
to have an issue down the line with
their tax collector
not being trained well enough they can
split that office
off of each other if they feel that's
necessary
um our association does provide a lot of
training we have a three-year
certification program
um that most new clerks attend i
attended it my first year i graduated in
the third year
i started um five years ago with no
experience as town clerk no prior
experience
and through the association through
reaching out to other clerks i learned
the position
um i don't really believe it's a good
excuse to make this an appointed
position because they don't feel that
someone will step up that someone is is
there able to do the job they would be
able to find someone
to do the job and to fill the the role
as town clerk
so i would suggest to them if they
if they feel that the tax collector
portion of it
a resident's not going to be able to do
they can split that off
and that's what they should do
our association
does not like this bill we we oppose
this bill and i'm open to any questions
are there any final questions for mr
healey from derek
mr chair
yes a quick question yes representative
guthrie on the committee thank you mr
chair
uh
is it fair to say
that gorilla should not be have any fear
in if we do uh
itl this bill
uh
and that seems what they the
uh the bill is to for a specific town i
know
my question
really is
if the selectmen in the town
have a concern as to who would be at
least a candidate
they can't they make sure that the town
clerk tax collector
uh retires in between the elections they
would appoint somebody
let them get real good training and then
that person run so couldn't the
selectmen have some input to that
position if it has to be
appointed in between in between the
elections
so they would um
the person appointed would be appointed
to the next annual election um so it
would be less than a year appointment
but if if they did it right after a town
election
the person would be in office for about
a year before the following election
would take place
i know in my town that's what we did and
it worked out good the person uh got
trained and she ran and is still running
and the three asking for a three-year
term
uh is not too much there's no guarantee
but that's what the job offers and i
don't think you can change that
yes and our association
is very helpful with new clerks they
have a new clerk workshop they reach out
they make sure to reach out to all the
new clerks let them know
what help is available
a clerk that's been doing the job for a
while will even go to that town and sit
there with the clerk and assist them and
make sure that they know what they're
doing so we do have the resources as an
association
to assist
new clerks so i don't really see this as
an issue
and it's really not an issue yet for
gorham they're kind of looking down the
road
but i mean the towns
are going to lose their clerks to
retirement it's been it happened in the
past where they take other jobs either
at the state level or with the city or
just a different position maybe a town
mandatory town administrator and the
town moves on they they find the right
person they train that person and they
continue servicing the town
thank you
we have one more hand up uh
representative
thank you this is a new question
uh thank you mr chairman uh thank you uh
mr healey
uh
our
the training you mentioned through the
association is that available to
just elected
clerks or can aspiring clerk someone
who's planning on running in the future
take the same training
thank you
so right now it's not everything that's
not in the position but it is open to
someone that's working in the office
so it's not open to just any resident of
the town we had that question come up
i'm actually on
uh the certification committee i'm the
vice chair for the association
um you have to be
in your position
you want someone to call in thank you um
okay
hearing
on hd 463 and move to open the hearing
on
php 467.
go back to 463 however let me report
that of those interested
in the bill we have three in support and
22 in opposition
all right hb 467
is a bill relative to current use tax
rate eligibility
and
let me ask if uh
if we have carrick guitar
that's pronouncing that name
directly from the new hampshire wildlife
federation who opposes the bill would
like to
speak mr chair i apologize for
interrupting but i believe the prime
sponsor is on the line to introduce the
bill
and the prime sponsor is who
uh representative ellen reed i could be
wrong but i do believe she is here to
introduce i'm here if you can hear me
i can hear you i don't have you on the
list to speak however
go ahead and go ahead and introduce the
bill please
thank you mr chair and thank you
honorable committee for the record my
name is ellen reed i do represent
rockingham 17 which are the towns of
newmarket and new fields i also have a
biology degree from vanderbilt
university i have another legislator as
well who would like to speak on this
bill
who has experience with conservation
issues uh she is involved perhaps in a
family emergency i believe she's on and
ready to testify but i just want to make
you aware in case uh she has to step
away
so i would like to start by talking
about the purpose of our current use rsa
obviously anytime you touch current use
rsa you're going to have a whole lot of
people interested in the issue and
concerned about whether or not the
changes are going to impact them
the current use law rsa 79a states i'm
going to shorten it uh it is hereby
declared to be in the public interest to
encourage reservation of open space
thus providing a helpful and attractive
outdoor environment for maintaining the
character of the state's landscape and
conserving the land water forest
agricultural and wildlife resources um
so i just give that very briefly as
background as to
the idea of why we have current use law
at all obviously current use as we uh
look at it is the purpose is to protect
farmers and other stewards of our open
spaces who provide us with a lot of
necessary services while protecting our
open space while engaging in that
conservation
um from the highest and best use tax
rate that private businesses um and
other entities that are not involved in
being stewards of our open spaces are
doing
however i would argue and i think it's
it's pretty obvious from our say that i
just read that if the organization is
actually involved in damaging
our wild lands our wild habitats for our
wildlife
and not conserving it
then
it would be an injustice to deny
from those municipalities that tax
revenue
that those businesses should be
contributing to when they are in fact
not contributing to the conservation of
our uh
wild uh wild lands and this is exactly
the case not frequently at all and i
want to make it very clear because i was
reached out to by a whole bunch of
different farming organizations and
private farmers worried about this
my intent in this is not to remotely
touch anyone we consider to be in the
farming or agricultural world
those people provide us with food and um
our tradition is deeply rooted in
farming uh i would never even think to
do that but we do have a couple not a
lot it looks like probably two
um
privately owned uh
recreational hunting clubs dedicated to
private membership recreational hunting
of exotic species
and there have been numerous examples of
those exotic species causing problems
and in fact
having the capacity to become invasive
new hampshire primarily i am concerned
about one
new hampshire has the largest private uh
private membership-based
exotic species uh recreational hunting
club east of mississippi you may know of
it it's called corbin park it is
famously um
private and exclusive uh
we don't have a lot of information on
for example their membership and dues
but from what little information um has
been made available through just
personal testimony it appears they have
maybe a couple dozen members uh almost
entirely from out of state a few maybe
in state paying about
approximately a six-figure yearly uh
membership due to hunt exotic species on
this private grounds it is a 26 25 or 26
000 acre uh property
and with approximately 26 mile perimeter
we don't know as i said already we don't
know uh
the all of these species that they
harbor there for this private hunting
recreation
but we do know that they
do quite a bit of harboring of eurasian
wild war
um for those of you who may not know
that is one of the species that has
become famously invasive in the south
and in the southwest in devastating
entire ecosystems down there one of the
species they also harbor elk
elk has the capacity to
compete
with our native white-tailed deer and
also it elk famously harbor a number of
diseases that are easily transmissible
to livestock animals um the elk as far
as i know have not yet become a real
world issue but certainly the bore most
definitely have uh numerous examples of
the boar escaping the facilities causing
real awful and i would implore you to
ask the fish and game department i'm on
the fish and game committee myself about
the devastation that those boar have
done to our new hampshire public lands
in terms of rooting up vegetation
um and damaging habitat also the boar
have damaged uh private property as well
you can there's numerous examples of the
residents in the uh in the area that
have had their private property damage
the bore have also caused traffic
accidents
and have actually procreated outside the
park now because this is a very private
these are not animals that fish and game
can regulate these are privately owned
animals it would be the same as if you
had cows on your property so when they
escape they are still considered under
law to be the private property of the
park but the escapes have happened so
much that now the board that have
managed to escape
um
while the law protects corbyn park to
say they can charge for the killing and
taking of those animals corbin park has
had to basically wave that because uh
just to enlist people to help control
the damage that the the wild boar are
doing
um
so the other uh facility i'm aware of
is a um a game bird
uh facility where uh and i believe uh
the akc uh has submitted testimony i
know she's here to testify
um and the idea is that these facilities
are
breeding or harboring
exotic game bird species to train
uh hunting dogs which is fine except for
the fact that again any anytime you have
the potential of a species becoming
invasive we're talking about encroaching
on our natural
new hampshire lands and i would uh posit
that we actually do have quite a number
of native uh game bird species that any
training facility could use in order to
train hunting dogs
um also i would like to point out that
there are a number of uh special laws in
fact the trans trespassing signs at
corbyn park highlight the fact that they
are protected by special law um for
those of you who may have seen some of
the news articles corbin park was
established by uh a i believe a steel or
railroad magnate named
excuse me austin corbin
um in the 1800s who was quite famously
very wealthy and powerful and
just as a way not as a way to inject any
other issues into this but just as a way
to to
go ahead and acknowledge the articles
that have come out yes he originally
created the park as a private club for
wealthy
white non-jewish
men um i'm not trying to inject that in
there but there have been a number of
news articles on that but that is not my
issue my issue is strictly on
conservation so as i said i do serve on
the fish and game committee i do
understand and respect that hunting when
in the context of science-based game
management plans is very important
helpful to our ecosystems we are not
talking about hunting in reference to
our natural native species we are
talking about bringing exotic possibly
invasive species that are doing damage
to our lands um and then
on top of allowing that which i'm not
suggesting we banned that
but on top of allowing that then giving
them a very very substantial tax
uh break which by all rights should go
to those towns
um so yes we are talking about the
privatizing of wild lands where they
stock exotic animals for
private people to kill privately owned
are animals willing to take some
questions
uh i am i would i would just like to
close very briefly with saying that i
have been again reached out to a number
of farm and other uh concerned interests
in every single case i explained to them
my intent and asked them if there was
any language at all that they would like
me to use to amend it i my goal is to
protect the farming community and so i
have not received any language from them
but i am still very very much willing to
work with anyone who would like to
detail this language to make sure our
farming community is protected but yes i
will take questions and before you do
that can i ask you to submit your
written testimony to the committee
sure
represent a reporter has a question
thank you mr chair let me get back on
screen here and thank you representative
reed for taking my question i'm not sure
you know the answer to this and i i know
i don't know the answer to this
um years ago when my life was different
i owned
my family owned a parcel of land that we
had in current use and we used it for
logging and um each so our property
taxes were reduced because of that but
we did have to pay a timber tax on the
proceeds of the logging
that went to the town
um do you know of any other
use of current use land
that would produce an income
for
someone produce revenue profit that
doesn't have to pay
anything into the town
in terms of taxes as a result
i'm assuming that farmland is a
different thing but
any other use of current used land
that makes a profit for the owner
whereby the owner doesn't have to
compensate the town for the use of the
land
other than thank you very much
representative porter for the question
other than the uh things that you
mentioned i know of none
um essentially businesses in the sense
that we think of businesses
would always have to pay some form of
tax uh and certainly that's even the
case for farms and as you mentioned
logging uh i would say as i stated in
the beginning of my testimony that in
the case of agriculture in the case
which i would extend to um the
harvesting of timber um these things
especially when they're done by and i
think we're mostly concerned about the
small farmer and the small time timber
harvesters you yourself were
these things can be done and should be
done in a sustainable way that works
with our natural ecosystem and not
against it so we do clear lands for
farmland for example so that's not
simply
not using the land you are using the
land but you're using it in a way that
is beneficial
for the ecosystem and beneficial for the
residents as well this is why we don't
want to tax them at that full highest
and best use rate they are protecting
the land and giving us something in this
type of situation that i've outlined and
i believe that the organization that
operates corbyn park is a non-profit and
it's not paying any kind of taxes um
in this in this is this is a situation
where it's not even really a business it
is a private club that is completely cut
off except for the fact that their
invasive animals are escaping and
causing damage
but there's really no oversight
law enforcement to my knowledge in all
of the years has only been on the
property once and only that was only
because a person was killed on the
property so there's really no oversight
over this particular property so i'm
again i'm not suggesting changing those
laws but i'm saying
there is no rationale therefore for then
giving them a giant tax break they
aren't doing the things that the other
entities like the timber harvesters and
the farmers are doing for for our
ecosystem in our community
thank you
next we'll go to representatives
uh thank you mr chair and thank you
representative reed for coming and
testifying i think you may have just
answered my question which was in regard
to
the bill is addressing the issue
of
the fact that
a private club
is receiving
a tax benefit
from the state of new hampshire
where they're not providing a benefit
back to the state of new hampshire in
the sense of
land that is open for
hiking or biking or
walking or
anything else because it's a private
club and your remedy is to
make this private club pay
the highest and best use for
for taxes not the current use tax
because they are not benefiting
the state am i am i correct
you are 100 correct representative and
it was very succinctly and well put
um
the details of corbin park it is
entirely surrounded by
the whole 26 miles of perimeter by a 12
foot high fence um which the boar are
very capable of burrowing under
um but uh there it's posted with no
trespassing and it's extremely well um
uh enforced and it's actually a lengthy
and kind of ominous sign that i'm happy
to share with the rest of the committee
so it is not open to any hiking bird
watching any kind of recreational use
outside of the people who are able to
afford the six figure ish membership
dues um and as you pointed out almost
all of the open spaces that we don't
currently do give current use um tax
credit to
can in fact enter into those agreements
to allow their spaces to be open to
hikers or even hunters that are actually
hunting our actual native species or
what have you any kind of recreational
activity but this is completely cut off
in its own bubble except for the fact
that their private animals that are
invasive keep escaping
thank you representative
and next uh we have representative
nanchikuri
thank you mr chair thank you
representative reed for uh taking my
question you talked about the invasive
uh non-native species of animals
breeding or growing in this how are
their feeding habits changing our
ecosystem in terms of vegetation because
they are non-native and i have two-part
question to that
and
also you know you talked about the
diseases that they bring how it is
affecting our natural ecosystem in terms
of our
native
um
animals
as well as the native vegetation because
we are bringing a non-native invasive
um
could become invasive and could affect
our natural ecosystem in new hampshire
which is our prime
duel or that's our basic
treasure
thank you so much for the question
representative magna pudi um
i
not being an employee of the fish and
game wildlife uh division uh don't have
detailed information but they do have it
on their website and i'm very happy to
send those links over to you all uh in
the committee um however very broadly i
can say that the wild boar i know we
don't when we talk about endangered
species we frequently don't talk about
uh plant species but we do have
endangered plant species wild boar can
upset the habitat for those endangered
plant species as well as habitat for um
or not just in danger but just
threatened uh animal species as well in
terms of the disease and in the wild
boar i think you can make a good
argument that they already have become
invasive because there are um instances
of individual board that appear to not
have come directly from the park but
maybe have actually bred outside of the
park
as they have done very extensively in
the south and southwest parts of the
country
the
disease that i mentioned in particular
with reference to elk which as i as far
as i know has not escaped the park yet
um
i mentioned that the elk could
out-compete our native white-tailed deer
but more importantly than that and
possibly moose though they do use
slightly different food sources but more
importantly they are a giant carrier of
several diseases including wasting
disease
which is currently
really impacting new hampshire's uh both
our
threatened moose population and our
native whitetail deer population which
is uh uh
is not as threatened obviously um but
that is the extent of my knowledge but
there is more information i'm happy to
provide to the committee
can i ask a follow-up question mr
chairman follow-up though let's uh let's
understand that we have nine additional
speakers on this bill
i understand uh
yes follow-up in terms of we address the
animals then the birds gaming birds so
there's a whole system ecosystem that's
being
shifted because of introducing
non-native species not only birds
animals
plants and how the pollination happens
outside the farm i mean outside this
private land and how it affects the
neighboring
farm
farmland
because of the vegetation changing
it is thank you representative
magnafoody it is a prime tenant of
conservation sciences all of the
different conservation science
disciplines um that we do not introduce
uh non-native species um or
there have been examples of of the
attempt to introduce non-native species
for other control issues mainly to deal
and remedy issues that were caused by
other non-native species being
introduced so it is a tenet to not do
that and certainly as you mentioned um
our tourism industry which comes to you
know comes to see
our wildlands
is our number two uh business in new
hampshire number two industry so we want
to protect that at all costs okay next
we have a question from representative
lasallis and here in the llp
yes thank you and thank you for taking
my question
it's it seems to me
that this bill
is attempting
to control non-native species
by taking away the current use
aren't there other laws that we have in
new hampshire
for controlling for instance wild boars
uh thank you uh representative lisales
for the question
um so
the short answer to that is essentially
no unless i think you were purposely
like bringing them in and purposely
releasing them but if you think about
any of our farms uh while i did exclude
non-domesticated species in order to
exclude all your regular farm species
but you know a cow is non-native right
you you can bring a cow there's no
regulation on you except for maybe your
possible your municipal zoning
ordinances there's no real regulation on
you for bringing a cow into new
hampshire and if the cow escapes it
escapes a lot of domesticated species
cannot become invasive because they over
you know many many many years of
breeding have become utterly dependent
upon human beings especially in our
rather unforgiving
climate but we do know obviously
wildlife in new hampshire exists and so
there are plenty of species that can
adapt to our climate um
so there's not a whole lot of good
you know laws in terms of you can't
introduce
there's some good laws around aquatic
species i think you can be fined for not
cleaning off the whole of your boat for
example
but
i don't know of any laws that would do
that and more specifically to the point
while yes i am my main concern is
invasive species
to say that i'm simply trying to get rid
of people bringing in non-native species
is not exactly the point of the bill the
point of the bill as representative
truleven very succinctly stated is that
we give current use for a very specific
reason we are getting something out of
it either in the stewardship of our wild
lands
in our ecosystem or you know in the
sense of provisions of food preferably
in a sustainable way
we aren't getting anything the state of
new hampshire is not getting anything
from this particular type of facility it
is not helping our ecosystem it's
damaging our ecosystem and these areas
are not open for people tourists or
otherwise unless they have a good good
chunk of money to to enjoy those lands
and again twenty six thousand acres
representative
from the committee
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you representative reed for taking my
question i'm curious if you have
considered or would consider
putting in some reference to how we
define
non-native and non-domesticated species
so that it is so that it removes the
ambiguity and i apologize if that
question was asked
uh before
thank you so much for that question
representative maggiore i
i
i could say that me putting this bill in
and trying to figure out what language
would be suitable was a heartache
because i
understand the need to balance ambiguity
like intentional ambiguity and broadness
with specificity
i opted for the simplest language i mean
you can also use that argument around
the word um harbor like what does it
mean to harbor
um and what i did instead is i just put
it out in the simplest language possible
thinking that if i tried to drill down
on different details that's more that
you know for us to fight over and i want
to just put out once again that i put it
in this broad language
or simple language not really broad but
um despite the fact that there is there
are definitions for invasive under rules
i don't know about statute
um and also domesticated we have we well
we actually do have statute that does
define domesticated species already so
um we do have some definition already
but i'm putting it out in the simplest
terms because i am very open to any kind
of amendment as you stated
in working with any party to amend this
in order to to get the right balance and
the right specificity down because again
this is not about 99.99 percent of the
organizations getting current use in our
in our state it's really as far as i can
tell only two organizations that are
potentially damaging our our ecosystems
and are receiving massive tax credits
for doing so
thank you representative lange
thank you representative lang so in
another half as as representative as i'm
also chairman of fish and games so my
question is around the conversation of
harboring non-native and
non-domesticated animals and as we had
that naming the trout bill and we found
out there basically no more native trout
in new hampshire that we've through our
our stocking policies have
um
basically
overridden a lot of our native trout um
and also around fish and games stocking
a pheasant which is not
uh
uh a non this is a non-native animal my
concern is could we be sweeping in some
farms that allow fish and game to stop
their their brooks and tryouts as well
as their fields with our with the
pheasant when they do their restocking
where those farms now have to give up
their current use rights
well that's certainly not my intention
and thank you very much
my chair
uh but
again i'm very open to any kind of
language that would get down to that
specificity if if we think that might be
an issue
i am specifically talking about
organizations that get the current use
credit
specifically for
the kind of bubble nature of bringing in
exotic species so um once again not
trying to impact 99.99
of the organizations that do including
the people who are just getting uh
current use and are allowing the fish
and game department themselves to stock
species
that uh won't become invasive
uh thank you our representative mcdonald
has a question
thank you remember mcdonald's
representative status
um thank you mr chair and thank you
representative reed for taking my
question
um
following up on the previous question
from your chair
i wonder if you would be amenable to an
amendment to the language that
specifically cited
tax exemptions for private hunting clubs
it seems to me that if that that would
solve it
um i yes i'm i'm open to any
any amendment that gets to the
aforementioned purposes of my bill as
i've said repeatedly
it's this very very specific problem so
anyone who can offer language that gets
to that in a way that upsets the least
number of people i'm very much behind
okay seeing no additional questions for
representative reid
to move on to my next
testimony
from
representative rum
yes good morning does every can everyone
hear me yes go right ahead oh thank you
very much mr chairman and thank you to
the members of the county municipal
government committee
um i come before you to speak in support
of hb 46 i'm yeah 467 i'm sorry and um i
submitted my written testimony
very early this morning so you should
have that
as ones who love new hampshire and all
that makes our state special i'm sure
that you join me in appreciating this
bill
it reflects on the intent of our state's
current use statute to preserve the
natural and traditional land use in the
granite state
however the new hampshire advantage
fundamentally relies on assessing
non-current use property to raise tax
revenue to fund local services including
public education we have been successful
since current use passed into law in
1973 in balancing lower revenues from
land and current use with regular tax
rates for other properties but it is
consistent with current use when land is
used to in but it is not consistent with
current use when land is used to
introduce non-native non-domesticated
animals for private paid recreational
hunting
is the legislative intent for wealthy
out-of-state hunters to stock private
land public use forbidden with
non-native species and pay handsomely to
hunt them
is it worth the risk of destroying the
habitat of our native species is that
the new hampshire way i don't think so
i believe that the current youth statute
needs to clarify that its intent is to
protect the natural and cultural
heritage of new hampshire
that is what this bill does
and i respectfully ask that you
recommend ought to pass thank you and um
also there's a couple things that came
to mind as representative reed was
speaking
one is that um she's referred to corbyn
park but
currently it's being referred to as the
blue mountain forest and game preserve
so if you are doing your own research or
background on this
you will find that name comes up quite a
bit
um there's a there's a person who
actually has logged in an entire history
of the blue mountain forest and game
preserve from back in the day when it
was established by austin corbin
and
it's under a website called em it's
mayette dot u s slash corbin park it's m
e y e t t e
dot u s slash corbin park you will find
a wealth of information there on this
much of it is anecdotal so i didn't want
to repeat it but if you want to get an
overall sense
then that that would be a good place to
go to
i also want to address a couple other
comments that
that were raised by
this committee during representative
reid's testimony
one is regarding the non-native trout
yes
the non-native trout have pretty much
replaced our native trout but they are
contained within a lake or a water body
so
unlike land where non-native species can
expand and there's just really no
boundary
invasive species in a water body can be
controlled um
i know that in uh we've had serious
issues in new hampshire lakes and rivers
with not invasive species of the plant
species
and even then it can still be controlled
to some extent we work very very hard to
control those species
um and it it and the danger is we can
get to a point where we're just running
in place that we may not eradicate them
but we can manage them
and i know with the situation with wild
boar that have escaped
they go in and do a lot of crop damage
of farms
they also displace some of the
food that native animals need
and i believe representative reed spoke
about the disease that can be spread
from elk to white-tailed deer
so i just want to bring that up um
i i've served on the uh aquatic invasive
species commission so i've
learned a lot about
um the the uh risk and threat that are
posed when we
allow non-native species to enter our
ecosystem
and that being said i would be very
happy to take any questions
thank you mr chair thank you
representative ron for taking my
question
um
you spoke about
you know both representative reed and i
rep you spoke about a specific
large forest in green game preserve uh
26 000 acres of land
uh
are there any
other
that you know off in our state that may
not be this large but they are
coming in small
areas
to
kind of take over
in my second question is in terms of
um
ticks and other parasites that live on
animal body
how does
non-native uh animals carry some of
those
kind of
parasites on them
that can
spread
diseases not only to the animals and the
environment but also the human because
they bring
new kind of parasite
like the lyme disease for example that
is native but are the other ones that
can bring
thank you
thank you representative manchapudi for
your question uh for the first question
no i'm not aware of any other um
hunting clubs or preserves that are
being formed
i first heard about corbyn park a few
years ago and my first question is
why are they under current use because
it's not a current use when we look back
at our natural and cultural heritage of
new hampshire to have exotic hunting
clubs especially ones that take up 26
000 acres
it's it to me it my biggest issue
with the situation and it's not just it
could be anybody it's just that
using current use laws
to reflect the intent
of the state the lawmakers that drafted
it
and in our government i mean when we go
through new hampshire and we look at
tracks of land that are in current use
it's a beautiful thing uh it's a
beautiful thing to see the florists
where people are allowed to hike through
they're allowed to go in and hunt
and they hunt native animals
but when you have such a large track
like um the blue mountain forest and
game preserve also known as corbin park
where the public is strictly not allowed
to go on um and if they did they're not
hunting our native species they're
hunting wild boar elk
bison actually that uh
corbin park used to be the largest
uh had the largest herd of bison in the
east of the mississippi at one point
so
um
it's a club
there's a lot of money involved but as
representative reed said it's very
secretive about what their finances is
but in totality of looking of all of
that it doesn't seem consistent with the
intent of current use
and my argument is then why is it
allowed to be in current use
okay
oh and i'm sorry your second question
sorry represent manchester united no i'm
not aware of it but um what i know of um
and generally speaking of uh exotic
species
that over time they do cause a lot of
damage we see it particularly now with
insects non-native insects coming in and
destroying tracks of of of timber
there was one species that was a real
problem for new hampshire before covid
where we had to really restrict people
bringing in firewood from out of state
um so
it's
protecting our state against
non-invasive species
is is is a lot of work it's we have to
be diligent all the time
but thank you for your questions
next question is from representative
blank
um thank you for taking my question i
guess my question is it said i believe
you served on a current use commission
of some sort
my conversation with the fish and game
executive director recently
i learned that there were three million
acres in new hampshire under current use
but only 1.5 actually allow recreational
access
is that consistent with what you know uh
thank you for the question
representative lang the uh commission
i'm on is actually the aquatic invasive
species commission i'm not on the
current use commission
but as far as your question goes
i i i think a lot of the land that is in
current use is pretty inaccessible it's
in the great northern in the great north
woods
um but
i do know um when you look at our
snowmobile clubs people are allowed to
cross on private property to travel
through to get to another trail
i learned a lot about that last year i
was on resources committee and we
studied a lot about
jericho state park up in berlin
uh you know there are uses
when we look back on what new hampshire
is and why we love new hampshire when we
look at current use those are uses that
make our state a better state
it preserves what's important to new
hampshire and what makes you new
hampshire unique
uh when i look at people using current
use for um
exotic animals hunting and trust me i
i um support hunting 100 percent
but it's almost turning a big swath of
current use into safari like where we're
hunting animals that would never be
found naturally
in new hampshire
is that an appropriate use to be under
current use and my opinion is it is not
okay the next question is from
representing stages
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative reed for taking yet
another question from me um i
look at this bill almost as trying to
put
the left-handed glove on the right hand
it's
it seems to me that the real issue here
is that this private club
is exempt from taxation
not
you know the the invasive non-native
species argument
you know starlings are invasive species
emus and llamas are non-native to new
hampshire i just don't know where that
argument begins or ends
but it does seem to me that the central
the nub of it
is the tax status of this private club
am i incorrect in that
oh thank you for the question
representatives davis i think the key
word here is domesticated when we look
at
emu llama farms in new hampshire i think
there's a couple llama farms
in hillsborough county that i'm aware of
they're domesticated they're used
they're being used for agricultural
business
and that's consistent with new hampshire
they're not exotic in the fact that
they're they're allowed to roam freely
to invade on an ecosystem of native
species
so i think that's the key differential
point
with this bill is that we're talking
about
exotic species being introduced and for
all intents and purposes
um just having free reign over our
natural ecosystems
representative reed spoke about the 26
mile fence well that fence is not
maintained very well it's very common
for
especially wild boar to escape
and and now they're starting to breed
outside of that preserve so
when you look at farms or agricultural
facilities that are raising animals that
are not native to new hampshire that's
essentially more of a farm they're being
they're contained they're being raised
for a purpose they're domesticated
so i think that's the i think that's the
um the the main point and that to me
that domestication agricultural business
is very consistent with the spirit of
current use
our next uh speaker is going to be
representative mason uh just to queue
him up we have additional questions from
the committee from representatives
and who's your question for
um i'm all set okay i've had my question
answered thank you mr chair
all right i want to uh
next recognize representative mason
who'd like to speak against the bill
thank you um
mr chair and committee
um
i'm in opposition to house bill 467 and
i ask you to motion to itl this bill
new hampshire current land use is really
developed in 1973 by the general court
the spirit of the law is to save new
hampshire's open space
by allowing private land known as an
affordable tax base for rural land usage
it's been established in a long proven
track record of success in our state
current use tax strategy works
congruently maintaining open land while
reducing urban sprawl
resulting in protecting our privately
owned forest agricultural lands wetlands
and wildlife habitat
additional incentives are allowed for
forestry stewardship programs thus
creating enhanced timber yield and
quality at harvest time this results in
timber tax revenue
it also plays a significant role
in providing views and vistas creating a
kaleidoscope of charm and charisma that
attracts tourists to our state of new
hampshire
it successfully adds private land use
trespass
giving opportunity for recreational
hikers skiers cyclists
water
recreation and atv snowmobiles bird
watches
to name a few
land owners have the right to keep their
land
closed by paying a higher tax rate
the current useful uh program creates
far more tax revenue and burden as open
land has fuse and needs few services
the tax incentive for these property
owners helps keep their private land
open and intact
since established the program has
protected
an estimated half of our 5.74 million
acres
and further estimates half of this land
is left open to public recreation so the
other half is closed
our current youth land
program has been examined and stood the
test of time rightfully protecting as
legislature continues to make the right
choices and shelter
the established current program
as proposed the amendment inclusion nor
shall open space include any farmland
forest land used to harbor non-native
non-domestic animal species
this opens a very large pandora's box
and jeopardizes many of our citizens
whose open space commitment the spirit
of the law places like corbyn park 26
000 acre preserve
established in 1890 maintains many
non-space non-native species as well and
would force an end to their current
youth status
the park managers
managed for 130 years of population of
non-native wildlife recreation hunting
harvesting by its owners and gas corbin
park
open space land practices wildlife and
forestry management along with wetland
protection
creating habitat for both non-native and
native wildlife corbin park has worked
with new hampshire foresters and loggers
creating jobs tax revenue
and timber tax
their forest releases result in
additional habitat natural feed for both
native and non-native species
the park maintains that this
current youth status is well within the
spirit of the law and is no different
than someone using
recreational land at home for
cross-country skiing under their own on
their own private land
corbyn may survive this incurred
legislation tax burden of house bill 486
but at the same time house bill 4 467
would have unilateral devastating impact
on many new hampshire landowners
new hampshire has additional upland
preserves
non-native
upland game bird species regulated by
new hampshire fish and game licensing
that would be affected it promotes
similar land management practices
maintaining excellent habitat for both
native and non-native species
these preserves a membership base with
family focus and open to the public
these provide countless hours of outdoor
experiences for many new hampshire
families that draw
from in-state out-of-state sportsmen
alike the preserves
offer a wide range of experiences and
work hand-in-hand with clubs and groups
and provide a safe non-crowded
environment for recreational shooters
hunters and dog trainers alike
in addition to hampshire fish and game
currently 21 licensed non-native species
game propagation growers are in new
hampshire
many whom would be forced to forfeit
their current land use or give up their
passion new hampshire sport dog owners
and trainers use current land use
throughout the state and often trained
with live birds
some of these dogs are used for field
trial competitions throughout the united
states and abroad
new hampshire fishing game stocks
pheasants on 13 privately regulated
shooting areas these landowners to
retain their current use tax credit
would be forced to close their land of
public use ending the cooperation and
use of new hampshire fish and game
jeopardizing the pheasant program
furthermore there's countless additional
non-native species at habitat and sea
calpa sea harbor examples
rock pigeon the starling
house finch
brown trout rainbow trout
state pigeon club exists that use homing
flight pens release on the current land
use
farms have large flocks of these birds
that sequin a harbor and feed off their
crop residue private stocking ponds
purchased and raised both rainbow and
brown trout
as written this language would end the
current use as we know it from personal
experiences on my own farm
in woodlands
that i haven't currently used i've
stocked my pawns raised game birds and
trained dogs i hunted these new
hampshire public reserves in new
hampshire fish and game stock sites
purchasing state licenses is required
under the amendment i would no longer be
able to raise game birds on my land
unless i gave up the current land use
benefit
many others would feel the same
financial strain
forcing the abandonment of their
passions
public hunting areas on private land
would be lost by devastating blow from
the hampshire fish and game pheasant
hunting program
this amendment language does not
this this amendment language does not
belong in our current land use program
and nor
does it intend
current use programs help us ensure that
new hampshire that we love
will be preserved for generations to
come i ask you to vote itl on this bill
representative reporter i had a question
for representative jason
no mr chair my hand is up by accident
uh
representative
11.
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
mason for coming and testifying before
us
um i'm wondering you've mentioned
current use several times and the
fact that new hampshire stocked some
pheasants
i'm wondering what you think about
uh 26 000 acres of land that is not open
to the public in any way shape or form
and
brings in
exotic
species that can
escape into
our quote-unquote
new hampshire natural environment
representative thank you for that
question
26 000 acres there's actually 1.33
million acres of current land use that
is not open in the state of new
hampshire to the general public the
landowner has the right to restrict it
by paying a higher fee on his
property tax and the current land use
they do pay property tax it's a reduced
rate so the land can stay open and it
can be used for services farmers
couldn't afford to farm the land at the
same tax rate that a house is taxed at
and and and their homes those that you
that are familiar with current land use
your home site and that you it's broken
off the areas around your home you pay a
full tax rate for that property
okay you get the break on the back land
the land that's used for for timber
management the land that's used for just
uh swamp land in new hampshire we've got
a lot of uh wetland in new hampshire so
those tax breaks are currently there
there if you've uh
ever have had chance to go up and see
the properties of corbin park a lot of
it's just the side of a mountain it's
very rugged land a lot of it
um
there's a lot of vistas and views
we've seen people
pull land out of current land use they
pay
a
penalty for that when it comes out when
they develop it
so um
this tax break
current land use has worked well to keep
new hampshire's
scenic
and if we start to meddle with it we're
going to lose that scenic look that we
we all so much love new hampshire for
follow-up mr chair
yes go ahead thank you mr mason could
you tell me where i could take a look at
the information you just shared with me
about the 1.3 million acres of land um
you can google that you can google that
quite easily thank you with estimates in
new hampshire uh current land use great
thanks very much i will is uh
representative manchester additional
question yes thank you mr chair thank
you representative mason for taking my
question
i have two questions one is uh you
talked about this being part of a
mountain's uh
side um
does this call we also have the view tax
in new hampshire where you know the
owners uh pay of
additional taxes if i have a good view
of the mountain or lake and i can't put
things up like sonari
does this
can
that be imposed on this current
land use
and
my second part is
there was a disease which dutch elm
disease that destroyed or killed
all our elm trees
and it didn't take too long for that to
happen and to bring those dutch elms
back
i hope uh representative manager just
so
i'm asking about the question in terms
of
the taxi you know land use
hold on a second please hold back
playing water yes listen
we're uh
well behind we're almost uh
two dollars behind here
i i like to
move things to speed things up a little
bit a number of questions
those kind of questions could be
discussed possibly during our executive
session
okay uh
i understand the point uh
so let me just express to the committee
to be brief in your questions and make
sure that the questions um she's
catholized but
considering the questions
also uh please don't want you
so my question is
to representative mason
in terms of
how long you know are you aware of the
fact that we lost
elm trees for dutch elm disease from the
beetle that came outside it was a
invasive beetle
and it's taking much longer so this
could if we don't take
notice right now this could affect our
natural beauty in new hampshire
and isn't that our responsibility
to be the stuarters of
saving our new hampshire natural beauty
well i
thank you representative i think i
understand your question um
it is our duty to police a lot of
invasion species
um invasive species though
the dutch elm disease that you speak
about that happened back when i was a
kid about 60 years ago and
one of the bigger ones probably right
now is is the beetle that came into
massachusetts and started this spread
and we've shut down a lot of border
lines with timber being able to cross
state lines and issues like that we do a
lot of preventative things to do that um
aphis comes in aphis is a animal plant
health federal programs and they come in
and they they'll take over some of those
uh
programs to make sure things are handled
properly like with that but
these animals
are really an eco-fusion animal they've
been here for a long time
these species didn't come in last week
into new hampshire
uh that we see inside corbin park uh the
pheasant has been here a long time
um the pigeon has been here a long time
they're all
species that have come in now i can tell
you point blank from pigeons
as as raising animals i have had animals
be condemned because of avian tb so does
that mean we do away of all the pigeons
that are in the state of new hampshire
but i have lost revenue and income on my
farm because i've had to do away
with animals
so
this becomes a very complicated question
and i don't think um there are many of
us qualified to really answer it
um
i don't know how else to answer that for
you but that's uh
uh thank you representative grayson i'm
next going to go to
yes mr chair i just have to
get there there we go okay should be all
set to go mr you are uh from the new
hampshire wildlife federation you want
to speak in opposite legislation at your
best
you asked for two minutes
okay perfect um thank you my name is
tara gateau i'm the executive director
for the new hampshire wildlife
federation
the mission of the new hampshire
wildlife federation is to be the leading
advocate for the promotion and
protection of hunting fishing and
trapping as well as a conservation of
and access to fish and wildlife habitat
with a affiliated membership of over 48
000 the new hampshire wildlife
federation represents the interest of
members from across the state
the new hampshire wildlife federation
would ask you to oppose house bill 467
and any attempts to target specific
properties currently eligible for
current use
the new new hampshire is home to
multiple shooting and hunting preserves
which would all likely go out of
business if this bill were to become law
these preserves operate on large track
of pristine and undeveloped land which
are maintained and protected to maximize
wildlife habitat
if these properties were no longer
eligible
for current use status the owners would
likely need to sell the land putting
large amount of protected land at risk
of development and permanent loss
hunting preserves in new hampshire are
source of revenue for the state
these facilities bring in tourists and
often host events which generate revenue
for new hampshire
these properties also bring out state
tourists into more rural areas in new
hampshire which benefit other local
businesses for this reason above new
hampshire wildlife federation asked you
to vote house bill 467 itl thank you
thank you are there any questions
for the speaker
seeing now but i'm now moving to robert
johnson
from the new hampshire farm bureau
federation
representative right
thank you mr chairman can you hear me
thank you
you've asked for three minutes i'm gonna
ask you to stick to two
okay thank you mr chair and members of
the committee for my record
for the record my name is rob johnson
and i represent the new hampshire farm
bio as a federation's policy director
farm bureau is a federation of new
hampshire's ten county farm bureau
organizations you can and consist of
membership of just under 2 000 family
farms and a little over a thousand other
supporting members
current use land assessment is the
foundation of our state's working farms
and forests
i want to stress that there is no
program more important to new hampshire
agriculture
we oppose any efforts that deviate from
the f
founding principle of current use and
oppose using the current use law to
address other objective objectives which
this bill does please do not go down
this road
we ask you to keep current use
the the focused open space program that
it is
and in closing i just like to speak to
the specific language that's proposed
our concern is that
current use landowners
harboring non-native
non-domesticated species of no control
or fault of their own and some others
that have not been mentioned we're
talking gypsy moss emerald ash borer
could be could be forced to lose their
their their
current use assessments fish and game
already requires and has authority over
non-native already regulates and has
authority over non-native
non-domesticated species
thank you for your time and
consideration
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions for mr johnson
to see that i'm going to move on to our
next speaker
joseph mullen
he's from the congressional sportsman's
foundation
you asked for three minutes i'm gonna
give you two
thank you mr chairman can you hear me
okay let's go right ahead
perfect thank you my name is joe mullen
i'm from grafton massachusetts and i'm
the northeastern states assistant
manager for the congressional
sportsman's foundation the 501c3
nonprofit i represent today
i would like to express our opposition
to house bill 467
i've also submitted testimony to the
committee so
for right now i'd like to touch upon
some of the high level points
with my time
several hunting preserve sporting dog
kennels receive incentives under the
current use tax assessment by conserving
the land water forest agriculture and
wildlife resources on their properties
because these operations use non-native
species under house bill 467 they would
become ineligible to receive the open
space land benefits and it's not
unreasonable to surmise that some of
these locations may look to
commercialize or develop their land
national participation in hunting has
been on a general decline and shooting
preserves offer new sportsmen and women
with the ideal opportunity to experience
time of field in a learning environment
additionally on these properties hunters
will often spend time on the site's
shooting range which
in conjunction with shots taken in the
pursuit of game
reflects contributions made to the
american system of conservation funding
a user pays public benefits structure
under which those who consumptively use
the resources
pay for the privilege and oftentimes the
right to do so in 2020 alone new
hampshire sports men and women generated
around 18 million dollars for
conservation through this system
part of which includes excise taxes on
sporting related goods such as
ammunition
uh another consideration i'd like to
provide is the effect that this bill
would have on sporting dog kennels um
you know
these kennels offer true conditions for
sportsmen and women to train their dogs
many kennels use non-native species in
their programs uh speaking from
experience my black lab trains over
birds that are non-native
um
so i know i'm short on time here uh with
this in mind uh
not all hunting preserves and sporting
dog kennels use non-native species such
as pheasant and hungarian partridges and
despite these game birds being a staple
pursuit in the upland hunting community
their existence in north america by
virtue makes them non-native and
non-domesticated uh once again i'd like
to thank you for your time
and reiterate my opposition to house
bill 467 thank
thank you any questions from the
committee for mr mullen
seeing uh the next speaker is that it
will be jason stock
from the new hampshire timberland owners
association
i've got two minutes for you just to
stop
good good afternoon can you hear me yes
okay uh thank you and and thank you for
the opportunity to testify
for the record my name is jason stock
i'm the executive director of the new
hampshire timberland owners association
we have about 300 members who own
and manage over a million acres of land
and most if not all of that is in
current use
and what's important to note is that
these landowners
everyone has a different management
objective
um there are landowners that object that
that
manage or their objectives include
recreation which could which could
include hunting hiking bird watching and
of course forest products
as well as just owning land for the sake
of owning land for its natural beauty
but if as mr johnson
uh had mentioned that current use is
really a fundamental underpinning to
private timberland ownership in the
state
and the the last clause in the in the
purpose or the declaration of the law
and i appreciate the sponsors
reading the first portion but the last
portion is just as important and that is
it shall encourage but not require
management practices on open space lands
under current use assessment
in other words current use is blind to
how the land is going to be managed it's
a very simple law and that's one of the
beauties of this law is that it looks
simply at is it developed or is it open
it doesn't
and and based on that that will
determine whether you are
eligible it doesn't get into are you
growing are you growing corn versus
trees are you managing for wildlife
versus managing for timber
so that's one of the beauties of the law
and it's one of the things that makes
new hampshire's i would argue one of the
best open space laws and policies in in
the nation
um
there was talk in the earlier about
you know that that it's a tax break and
i always bristle a little bit because
it's not really a tax break what it is
is it's an assessment of the land on its
ability to grow a farm product
or a timber product it is a different
way of assessing land
as opposed to say growing single-family
homes growing commercial development it
is an assessment on it
and
this is doc this is a chair can i ask
you to try to rap yep and i'll just
thank you
the benefits um i just want to also
mention that there was talk about
benefits
their current use land is eligible you
can post it
but even posted land provides benefits
such as scenic abilities
clean air clean water etc and i would
argue that that holds true to corbyn
park it is clear this bill was
introduced targeting a specific
landowner because
they
someone does not agree with how they're
what they're managing for
and for that reason i urge you to vote
this bill inexpedient to legislate
i'd be happy to answer any questions
and i appreciate your time this
afternoon thank you
the range questions from mr stock from
the committee
seeing the next speaker i'm going to
call on is a member
one more time sorry about that yes and
ready to go
okay uh mr royal uh
this floor is gonna be yours you've
asked us two minutes you got it
thank you mr chairman and thank you
honorable members of the committee
my name is scott rouleau i live in
hillsborough new hampshire
i'm the owner of far view farm in new
england upland llc
i'm also the president of the new
england chapter of pheasants forever
which is a conservation group focused on
the improvement of pollinator and upland
habitat for all species
including native and non-game birds as
well as small game
far view farm is a mixed use property we
have hay fields grow buckwheat sorghum
corn have wetlands a pond a brook
running through it which the state
stocks with trout you also keep bees for
pollination honey and their wax
and are licensed by new hampshire fish
and game
to keep pheasants for dog training
hunting and ultimately table fare
our property is less than 400 acres and
we are mostly in current use
i'm opposed to this particular bill
primarily because of the language being
as vague as it is
related to the species that we keep
pheasants have been talked quite a bit
regarding um this particular bill from
some of the earlier
folks that discussed it and given that
the state releases these birds um on
many other land owners land
and the fact that these birds are not
uh raised in the wild they're actually
raised in captivity you know one could
assume that they were domestic
you know we have
a business that's open to the public
we're not private like corbyn park
as some of the other people test their
testimony stated
we have many many users of our facility
throughout the state of new hampshire
and if we were to lose our current youth
status
you know our business would be in
jeopardy of going under
so based on that you know we certainly
are opposed to this particular bill
thank you any questions from mr keane
before we move on
see seeing none you mean mr lowe
rule i'm sorry
i'm
sorry uh
next speaker is going to be mr king
ahead of myself a little bit who wants
to speak in opposition
to the
bill you've asked for five minutes i can
give you three
representative manchurian you do you see
him in queue
he is in queue and he is unmuted right
now mr keane uh do you want to speak in
opposition to the bill i'll give you
three minutes
he now has his hand up
i've recognized him
and he needs to unmute himself
i'm going to promote him to panelists
and see if that works
alright
why don't you hear me now
yes we can hear you very well i can give
you three
think i have figured it out
just deep into the pandemic i will be
very uh succinct mr chairman and members
of the committee i'm opposed to hb467 i
am a citizen of uh sony new hampshire
but i am also the senior vice president
and general counsel for the national
shooting sports foundation which is the
firearms ammunition hunting and shooting
sports industries trade association our
members include companies such as
six-hour ruger and many many firearms
retailers
throughout the united states and
including for you far view farms which
you just heard from mr rulo
this legislation is clearly aimed if you
pardon upon at corbyn park much of the
discussion has been about issues
surrounding wild boar escaping from the
property
this legislation does not really truly
address the purported issue it's trying
to solve i view this as anti-hunting
legislation that will hurt
shooting preserves like mr rulo's that
he just described and reduce access and
opportunity the purpose of the fair use
is to promote conservation
and so by doing away with this credit
you will be hurting conservation because
as mr rulo explained he would likely
have to go out of business it would also
impact animal agriculture such as for
example a yankee farmer in warner which
raises buffalo for sale
in the state
and that is obviously a non-native
non-domesticated animal and i would also
point out that elk are in fact native to
new hampshire while obviously they are
not in any great numbers in the wild
they are not a non-native species so
that is
incorrect information much of what we
heard earlier is simply not factually
correct
this
if you want to address an issue of wild
war it should be taken up by the fish
and game commission not by this
committee which will hurt farmers and
small game preserves in kennels in
hunting dog
training locations so i thank you for
your time and i ask you to oppose this
legislation any members of the committee
have a question
mr keane
seeing that last speaker
on this bill is donald mcfarland a
member of the public
i am looking mr chair
oh yep
he's from orange new hampshire
my video should be good
can you promote me to panelists
i can
mr mcfarland you've asked for three
minutes i'd like you to try to get to
your points in two
okay i just got rejoined i i missed what
you just said mr chairman can you repeat
that
you've asked for three minutes of speed
i'd like you to try to get to your key
points in two
i will endeavor to do so and i think a
number of the points that i wanted to
speak on have already been covered so
we'll see what i can do
um just to
cover where we are
that i think some of these things have
already been discussed uh representative
reed indicated that her language is
simple and yet she acknowledged up front
that she knew that there are clear
weaknesses with her wording
if we can't find simple language that
will suffice i have very little
confidence that making the language more
complex will make the legal
interpretations upon this clearer
uh domestication
is by no means a binary of a black or
white uh definition it is a continuum
and it is a rather subjective one at
that
we have a number of definitions if you
just go and google domestication you can
find many for yourself which make it
clear how complex uh that definition is
representative manjapuri uh asked about
the definition of native versus
non-native species of animal
i put it to you that you know she is
very much right to question what
constitutes a native uh and domesticated
species
uh i dare say i qualify as non-native to
new hampshire for that matter to the
continent although it's not clear from
the bill are we talking about new
hampshire or the us or america
my wife and i were talking recently
about the possibility of
purchasing some highland cows for our
farm
and
even although we'd be doing it from
stock that was uh grown here in
this nation
uh it would not be from this state
and it would not be any that have as
provenanced and historical a
relationship to new hampshire as the new
hampshire elk uh and wild boar uh in
corbyn park
uh and from time to time for that matter
my wife has suggested that i may not be
wholly domesticated so should my farm
and forest land be removed from current
use because of myself
it's absurd and and i think we've
addressed that but i think as you look
as a committee at changing the language
which clearly you would need to do if
this were to be passed i suspect that
there is very little language that you
might find that would not have other
issues as well
moving on
um the purpose of current use i think mr
mason addressed fairly well so i won't
spend much time on that
other than to say that
the the question that was first posed by
representative trelevan and a good deal
of the additional commentary that
followed there from
seems to imply
that current use is about having the
land be open to the general public it is
about what are we getting from it that
we're not getting anything from it was
discussed several times
that was never the intent
nor the stated purpose
of the current use laws as as and when
they were enacted or as and when they've
been revisited and modified many times
over the years
we the people of new hampshire
just as i decided when we passed rsa 79a
that it was in our interest to tell
people precisely what and what not to do
with their land no i don't think so what
in fact happened was that we determined
it was in the public interest to
encourage the preservation of open space
and if you read the statute you will see
that stated very clearly there better
than i can do it right now
26 000 acres of open space with a
handful of structures on it and with
careful and well-funded management of
the flora and fauna thereon is precisely
the sort of purpose that was
contemplated when we passed the current
use laws here in this state
our current use laws were instrumental
in my making a decision
to move to new hampshire and to choose
this as the state i wanted to live in
and grow my family in and to earn wages
and pay taxes
both property taxes and other taxes
within this great state this is a
slippery slope
and i'll move to the next point that i
wanted to make which is about the
sponsor's intent
i i read this bill
last night by happen chance because i
planned to come today
uh unfortunately not in person to state
house but but to testify on another
matter
and i was horrified to see this
because it struck me
when i first read it as an attack
against corbyn park
if you wish to attack the blue mountain
forest association and you point out
that they are already recognized
explicitly by name in existing statutes
uh existing rsas
then call them out by name
representative reed made no bones about
it this was her intent
to go after corbyn park
and she's not too worried about the fact
that there's maybe one other
in her view uh
club or park or whatever that
could be included as well
if that's your intent
then put it in the bill
and if it was a bill that said so if it
was a bill that said this is about going
after corbyn park
i would regard that as obscene overreach
by the sponsor
were this a socialist state i should not
be surprised to see such spitefulness
against citizens who have done well
themselves and attain some other measure
of wealth and enjoyment
that was a significant reason for my
emigrating from the united kingdom
and coming to this fair land and i'm
appalled
to see
what has been done here by the sponsors
of this bill and those who would support
it
they i have two small points left that i
i will wrap up as soon as i can mr
chairman
the first is
that this is not
a novelty
we have had many prior bills
intended to attack corbyn park
a number of of recent bills even we had
a bill just last year
that attempted to impose a safari
hunting license house bill 1573.
if you're going to make an argument
that we're not getting enough funds in
to take account of wild boars that
escape
and which frankly are quite
satisfactorily hunted by the neighbors
of that park today without incurring
substantial costs but nevertheless if we
believe there are costs there to address
then at least house bill 1573 addressed
it
by bringing funds in for the fish and
game department
it didn't attempt to say
let's assume that that corbyn park is
about growing school children
and growing residential waste
and requiring snow plowing of their
property
and requires huge increases in local
taxation for them
the the purposes here are not even
slightly aligned
the final point that i will make
is about the fiscal impact and i note
that there was no fiscal note on this
bill
will we add a fiscal note to reflect the
likelihood of litigation
and to reflect the possible need to
compensate people for this what amounts
to a taking
of of land
and of enjoyment
in conclusion
i've never set foot in corbyn park
and yet it gives me great satisfaction
to know that those 26 000 acres of open
space have been and are being preserved
with well-funded management practices
and to know that we have a place in new
hampshire where we allow the majestic
and i might add tasty new hampshire elk
and wild boar to rome
please vote in expedient to legislate
on this bill thank you
i thank you mr parliament
i remember the public nancy holmes would
like to speak at to
please
state where you're from and whether you
support or oppose the film
hi my name is nancy holmes i did sign in
as opposed to the bill i've been
listening along to all the testimony i'm
here from new boston today i'm not a
hunter i am in favor of keeping as much
land in new hampshire open as possible
because i love it
um but i want to correct a couple of
things that i've heard stated as facts
which i'm pretty sure are not facts
you've all heard plenty about how the
fact that current use is not a synonym
for public access so you know that
but another statement that was made is
that the buffalo that are sitting on our
farmers lands in this state are
domesticated tame animals they are not
just because an animal is being kept in
captivity that does not make it tame
if keeping it in captivity did make it
tame that would mean all the animals on
corbin park would of course be
domesticated animals
and i don't think that's exactly what
anybody means to say
um the akc hunt clubs are another big
group that are going to be impacted if
this bill goes through
and this is not a bunch of rich people
coming in from out of state this is all
your local guys who want to train their
dogs and excuse me your local ladies too
because i know several ladies who do
um
corbin park has been in place since 1890
as far as i can tell
um
and that means for 130 so years
this park has been in place without any
devastating impact on the environment i
do believe that the instance where
um and i'm sorry i'm old for me they
were russian wild boar not eurasian
but um the russian wild boar i believe
their escape and uh as breeding colony
into new southwestern new hampshire came
about during a hurricane in the 1930s
um so this is there may be some newer
escapes that i just haven't heard about
in the paper but there is a situation in
the southwestern part of the state where
there are uh wild boar reproducing as
far as i know not on the game preserve
and have been for a long time that would
mean that everybody whose land they are
on would suddenly use current lose
current use under this bill so the
people who farm emus ostriches buffalo
red deer
um
and the way it's written is so vague
that it would include the people who are
raising hedgehogs and um sawford african
rats that they breed for use in feeding
snakes and oh god help the poor people
who are raising boa constrictors
this bill is really bad i really believe
it needs to be itl
um and
when i looked at this bill
and after listening to all everybody
today what i came down to is this is
that
this park probably
uses local food for animals and people
it's a tourism destination
it is not
a non-producing
area in
the state
it um
and what i'm hearing from the sponsors
of people who are for this bill is how
dare those rich people be invited into
our state by a club they belong to in
order to be tourists here and practice
in
what they choose to do as a tourist
which is hunting on a private preserve
uh this kind of discrimination is
terrible so yes i'm just going to say i
think you should itl this bill
thank you chris holmes uh
our next speaker is from the public jake
mcguigan
mr chair i just need to let you know
that my husband has come home for his
new england lunch
thank you for uh letting us know
um
cheer dolan you on the line
yes sir chair i appreciate it
uh i would ask you so you could limit
your comments to two minutes it'll be
one it'll be one minute
please tell me where you're from whether
you oppose or support the bill sure jake
mcwiggin managing director of state
affairs for the national shooting sports
foundation you heard earlier from
mr larry keene who is a resident of new
hampshire
again we represent manufacturers
preserves retailers throughout new
hampshire and throughout the country i
just again want to echo the sentiments i
had sent written
opposition to 467 in earlier today to
the committee i want to echo the
sentiments of the new new hampshire
wildlife federation new hampshire farm
bureau scott and then also new england
upland
who is a member of ours
as well again just so you remember and
it has been pointed out sportsmen are
the largest conservationists in the
country and in new hampshire
these people that do come into your
state they are spending money they have
a large economic impact not just at
corbyn park but in the various preserves
around new hampshire so again we ask you
to uh oppose hb 467 and thank you for
the time today appreciate it
thank you mr geiger
lastly we have a
member from the public would like to
testify peter crawl peter please tell us
where you're from and whether you
support or oppose the bill
uh yeah this is peter kroll i'm from
springfield new hampshire i'm the
president of corbin park and i am uh
absolutely opposed to this bill
i we are
you know 25 000 acre
land management company in the upper
valley
we house uh
obviously we have the bore and the fence
to keep them in
but we have a lot of members most of our
members are from new hampshire most of
our guests are from new hampshire some
from outside the state
and
we
maintain the property as a you know it's
a big preserve it's it's a large piece
of land that's
undeveloped in the center of the state
and a bill like this could force its
development
so anyway i'd like to thank thank you
all and i hope that you vote this uh
inexpedient to legislate
thank you uh thank you for your
testimony um
at this point uh
having no additional uh comments in
queue
i'm gonna
recess the hearing
rather than include the hearing in hp
and uh
we're gonna
take a recess for lunch and we will
reconvene
at 1 20 p.m
and we will take up hb 486 at that point
and then 5 12 and 5 45 after that and
then we'll go right into the executive
session
so uh
we'll be back from lunch at 1 20.
mr chair
it's representative porter just want to
remind you we can hear when this
we can hear
i have just muted the room thank you
representative porter
whose cat was meowing
46.
talk about something
or i'll say something and they go that's
terrible thing to say
oh it's my ass burgers
and they go oh my god
[Music]
well you know you do watch the uh the
screen pretty closely
i do but today i didn't bring my
computer so i'm watching you on my phone
my chromebook ran out of juice
says i had 15 minutes left and i
prefer not to run it down all the way to
zero
mr chair can you hear me mr majori yes
i've just deleted the room
outstanding i'm just noticing that
um
the prime sponsor
uh the prime sponsor is listed for our
next bill
uh on the list to speak but i see only
bunny has rep
listed on the on on our list of
attendees i i'm gonna make a guess that
that's representative fellows
and and run through that and if i'm
wrong i guess we'll just we'll manage
from there
i have three people listed to speak one
is tony kaplan
yup dally
yes i have that too and i'll i'll do my
best to find them
um
sally fellows is the prime sponsor
and tony kaplan is is not on yet
and
um
mick lynch is not on yet so
this could be a quick one if if the
person listed just as rep is not
representative fellows we'll probably
just need somebody to introduce the bill
but we'll take that
up when we get there
oh wait thank you no i can do that
introduction if need be
and i and i found uh i found jeff mc
lynch
where'd he go
yes
tim do you know of any efforts
to give some sort of bonus
compensation
to national guard members
are you not i i don't think anything
like that was in the uh latest stimulus
package of washington so i'm not
familiar i do i just think
that
we owe
those folks so much
i agree i went over and did the testing
last uh last saturday or before our
session
and uh they were phenomenal
they
ran an efficient shops it took over the
old sears and they did it like a
drive-in literally they rolled the doors
up they pulled sixteen cars in
that bank opened up the other side that
sixteen cars out closed it opened up at
sixteen more eight
and there was it was like
my wife and i went to get our
vaccination
last
thursday after session
at
snhu
the national guard was was running it it
was amazing they had cars
all kinds of lines of cars
and it was like they had them all herded
in different directions and they hustled
they were pleasant they were great
and
you know when you think about them all
they've done for us over the past year
or so
my gosh hey you guys ready yep
okay this is the municipal and county
government committee here
on the 1st of march 2021 we are entering
the next hearing
on the bill the house bill 486
mr
chair i just have a quick question about
the previous bill
blue sheet please
hb 467
46 support and 41 opposed
46 support 41 opposed
okay and likewise on hb 486
that we're going to talk to now
we have 87 in support and three opposed
okay this is a bill that uh changes the
um
the the low and moderate income property
tax uh levels
uh
against the statewide education property
taxes so
let's begin the testimony the bill
sponsor
sally fellows
representative fellows
yes it is representative fellows is it
possible to be promoted
yes
uh
you're in support of the bill
you've asked for 10 minutes could i ask
you to try to save that a little bit
okay i think i'm all set
okay so
thank you thank you um chairman dolan
and committee members i'm representative
sally fellows i represent plymouth
holderness and hebron and i'm here to
introduce hb 486
on saturday i emailed all of you my full
testimony as well as a spreadsheet of
the payment history of this program so
today i'm sure you'll appreciate that i
will just go over the main points
low and moderate income homeowners
property tax relief program
is intended to help low-income people
many of whom are senior citizens remain
in their homes
but the program is in danger of
disappearing
in the first year of the program which
was 18 years ago
of new hampshire homeowners applied and
received a total of 7.5 million dollars
in rebates
since then participation has slowly
decreased
last year
just 1.5
percent 1.5 received a total of less
than 1 million dollars
so
one of the reasons for this decline in
participation is the shrinking side
size of the rebate amount
in the beginning the maximum rebate was
almost 500
and that was that was 18 years ago
last year the maximum rebate was 183
dollars
and this year it will drop to about
160 dollars
and those amounts i i'll remind you are
just for the very lowest income level
other people that do qualify would
receive only 60 40 or 20 of that maximum
amount so 20
of 60 160 is only 32
so you can understand why maybe some
people are not applying for it anymore
participation has also dropped because
fewer people
now have incomes that fall below the
income caps that were set in 2002.
the only people who get the maximum rema
rates now are single homeowners
with an adjusted annual gross income
below 12 500
or a two people or more
uh household with the income below 25
000.
so participation and rebate amounts will
continue to drop
unless we raise those income limits
and
the property cap value that is in the
build right now it's set at a hundred
thousand dollars of property value for
the rebate
this bill will increase the maximum
rebate to about
350 dollars for next year and make more
people eligible
so i ask that you please help low income
people particularly the seniors remain
in their homes
by passing this bill
with this bill they can once again get a
meaningful
property tax relief
in the form of a rebate on their
statewide education property tax bill
so
i can take any of your questions i would
just add
that
compared to my
testimony that i emailed you i did
include
one additional piece of information
today and that was the part about
of the
homeowners received rebates at the
beginning
and only one and a half percent are
receiving them now so i'm happy to take
any questions
thank you uh representative mccoy
yes mr chair just a brief one
representative fellows um
you this is the same bill only modified
with new numbers that you presented to
this committee
last year um
representative porter that's uh correct
the the i
both last time it wasn't last year it
was actually two years ago
but um what i did in both cases is i
used census data
to compare to the original program back
in
and updated them
based on that and i did the same process
again so it's the same bill as two years
ago although the caps in the amounts are
higher now
thank you mr chair thank you
representative fellows for taking my
question
how does this reflect our census data in
terms of new hampshire
aging population what was the census
in 2002
and now we in the last few years we have
become number two or number three in the
aging population in the country isn't it
um thank you representative
the i can't answer that question about
the senior population although with it
with a with a specific um number for you
but i do know that that is indeed the
case because we hear repeatedly on the
news that
new hampshire has either the highest or
the second highest percentage of senior
citizens
the actual census data that i used
is broken down by
income category
so
i used to do the update
follow up mr chair yes go ahead and
follow up
thank you um this also
shows that
properties taxes being the prime
revenue for our state
this is a push and pull in terms of
do we raise you know we are raising the
property tax but not getting the rebates
so that burden shift has happened isn't
that
true
um thank you representative um
i can tell you that that is going on in
terms of property tax as a whole
this particular bill though
deals only with the statewide education
property tax
and that's been on tax bills for almost
20 years now the amount
let me put it this way the rate of that
tax has gone down over the 20 years
but
the
prop the property values have gone up
so when you have
the same rate
and
property values go up then the tax bill
increases when you have the rate going
down and the property values
going up
in proportion what you end up is the tax
bill is actually about the same
so the statewide education property tax
bills that people are getting
now are about the same as they were 20
years ago assuming you have you know the
same home and all that
um the the
one of the reasons this rebate is going
down is because the home that was worth
um
100 000 let's suppose somebody had a
homework worth a hundred thousand
dollars
20 years ago now it's worth um
two hundred thousand dollars
but they're only getting the rebate on
half the property value and half of what
they paid in instead of getting the
whole amount that they were
20 years ago
okay next
question we have is
representative
uh thank you mr chairman uh thank you
representative fellows for
answering our questions so
this is kind of
new to me i didn't
so this is a program that isn't a buy-in
from the towns this is actually
a program with this with the state is
that correct
yes yes representative that's correct
um
this has
nothing to do with local
property rates or
taxes aside from the fact that it
appears on your property tax bill
this is a tax
property tax
by the state
and the program started 20 years ago at
the same time
that
in response to the claremont lawsuit
this was back when governor shaheen was
governor in response to that lawsuit
the state
said that they would
use a property tax to show a bigger
share of state contribution to funding
education so that's when it appeared on
the property tax bills
and what what happens with that um
money is
the
local
town clerk's
tax collectors collect that money and
they send it over to the school
districts and that becomes part of the
adequacy aid money that
is booked as being from the state
next we've got representative kaplan
who'd like to offer some testimony as
well
mr chair i cannot find uh representative
kaplan in our list i do see jeff mc
lynch but not representative kaplan yet
let's move to mr mcglinch who is in
support of the bill he's from the new
hampshire school funding fairness trump
he asked for two minutes
uh thank you mr chair uh can all the
members of the committee hear me all
right yes go right ahead wonderful well
uh chairman dolan representative porter
members of the committee thanks so much
for the opportunity to speak with you
this afternoon for the record my name is
jeff mcclinch and i'm the project
director of the new hampshire school
funding fairness project we're a
non-profit organization that seeks to
educate
citizens and policy makers about the
system new hampshire uses to fund its
public schools
to build awareness of the shortcomings
of that system
and to advocate for changes in law that
make that system
more equitable for students and
taxpayers alike
as house bill 486 would make real
progress in improving taxpayer equity we
strongly support this bill and urge the
committee to recommend it as ought to
pass
as members of this committee are aware
one can't discuss new hampshire's tax
system without talking about the
property tax it's far and away the
largest tax collected in new hampshire
generating close to four billion dollars
to support state and local public
services in 2019 um
yet that property tax is also an unfair
tax as it pays places a far greater
responsibility on low and moderate
income taxpayers than it does on more
affluent ones uh the latest data that we
have from the institute on taxation
economic policy
suggests that the poorest twenty percent
of new hampshire households those are
households with incomes under
twenty six thousand seven hundred
dollars
paid roughly six point two percent of
their incomes in property taxes in 2018.
stark contrast the wealthiest one
percent of households each of which had
an income in excess of
514 000
paid an effective property tax rate of
just 1.9 percent
now despite new hampshire's heavy
reliance on the property tax and in turn
that tax is heavy toll on the lease well
off
the state does very little to mitigate
the impact of the tax on those
struggling to make ends meet
as representative fellows has already
discussed
the state's principal approach to
property tax relief the lower moderate
income homeowners property tax relief
program that's the subject of this bill
has all been evaporated in recent years
and she provided very detailed
information about that so i don't want
to belabor that point
and as she also discussed
the bill before you would seek to
reverse that trend and to aid new
hampshire uh homeowners facing financial
hardship both by expanding the number of
taxpayers who could take part and the
value of the rebates that would they
would receive
in bolstering property tax relief house
bill 486 is consistent with one of the
key recommendations
offered by the recent commission to
study school funding as members of this
committee may know that commission met
for much of last year despite the
pandemic and received hours of input
from school finance officials
tax administrators academic experts and
members of the public
they examine new hampshire's school
property tax system at length
and after doing so they recommended that
among other changes and i just want to
quote from the report
the state should enhance taxpayer equity
through property tax relief targeted to
homeowners and renters through a low and
moderate income property tax relief
program
this program should include should
include updated limits to income home
value and net worth and be
satisfactorily funded by the state
and one final point i'd like to offer is
that at the present time the house
representatives is actively considering
changes in tax law intended to spur
economic growth and ease the difficult
economic situations many families now
face through the pandemic
any effort to use new hampshire's tax
system to achieve those ends should
start with property tax relief efforts
along the lines of house bill 486 house
bill 486 would put money in the pockets
of granite staters still coping with the
economic consequences of the pandemic
and thus allowed them to shop and spend
at local businesses striving to remain
open
for these reasons i once again urge the
committee to recommend house bill 486 as
on to pass and i look forward to working
with the members of committee to make
new hampshire's tax system more fair for
everyone i'd be happy to answer any
questions you might have you know
florida do you have a question
yes i do mr chair thank you and thank
you um mr mclink for taking my question
um i
am i correct in saying that when a
taxpayer applies for this rebate
it does not
it is not taken from the town's coffers
in any way nor does it impact
the um funding that school systems get
am i correct that's absolutely correct
um to i believe another rep's point
earlier about whether cities and towns
opt in they don't this is universally
available for anybody
with income below certain levels it's
available not just to elderly homeowners
but to um you know younger ones as well
should their incomes be sufficiently low
and it doesn't in any way figure into
the calculation of aid that they
uh that those cities and towns receive
for school funding
while the funds come out of
the education trust fund
that that trust fund as you know is
always made whole if needed
by the general fund
so so
increasing the limits so that people get
higher rebates is not going to have an
effect on the budget for the
hillsborough deering school system or my
or my local property taxes that's
absolutely correct and if i could expand
on a sort of discussion that was offered
earlier um while this is tied to the
statewide property tax
that tax has
um over time played a smaller and
smaller role
in funding
schools and so there's every reason to
increase
this relief because much of the job that
that tax was doing is now being
pushed down onto localities and so
relief really does need to be expanded
to make up for that thank you
all right thank you there are a couple
of hands raised but uh i was considering
taking this to an immediate executive
session both
i just wanted to clarify that the
process to get the rebate is that the
the homeowner pays the tax bill to the
town
and then sends a form to revenue
administration and revenue
administration sends them a check
thank you and representative
you want to make an additional comment
yeah thank you mr chair uh this is to
either representative fellows or i
didn't quite get the name of nhs
ffp person
um
my question is that property tax is
collected in two parts right one is at
the state level
and one at the county
level so this is the state's portion of
it that pays towards the education
funding
so
this
clearly shows
or at least in my
you know
pushing the
responsibility and
uh expense to the
local
and not providing that relief at the
state level am i making sense
no
i yes yes um representative benjamin if
if you look at a tax bill
there will be a line for the municipal
tax for the town or the city tax there
will be one line for the state um
education property tax and another line
for the county tax and then sometimes
there are different like you know
like water districts or something on
there also
so they're all separate they're on all
on the tax bill and you pay them all at
once but they're distinct amounts
okay okay uh
at this point
i'd like to move uh i'd like to conclude
the hearing
on this bill in 486
and i'd like to take immediately into
executive session
so i look i'd like to uh
i'm looking for a motion for
representative tripp
any discussion
motion is about to pass
on house bill 46.
uh
mr clerk would you take the role
there we go out to pass on
hb46 representative martin yes
workforce yes
representative tripp yes
representative guthrie yes
representative
yes
representative melvin yes
representative
yes
representative power
representative porter
yes
representative
representative sweetie
yes
and representative
mr chair isn't this fm can you place an
fn on uh
consent calendar
no it has to go to finance first and
then go and consent
this goes to finance
committee for a second committee
i thought that was too late for them
all right next uh
that will conclude the executive session
at this time
next uh hearing is on
hb 512
which is
a bill relative to emerging emergency
housing assistance
mr chair i have another uh procedural
question
um
isn't it a little late for the second
committee assignment didn't we have to
do the second committee
uh bills
before yeah last week's session
uh i i believe we we did but uh
representative lang can you help me on
this yeah sure so uh this would be a
second committee deal but because that's
just know if he's going to recollect a
set calendar um it doesn't know
[Music]
okay
does that clear it up
i did i didn't hear it i didn't hear it
i will not go to the finance committee
but it will go on a regular calendar
okay so the next uh bill is house bill
which is which has to do with emergency
housing assistance
and
we have
is it
casey conley is
that
going to be
the prime sponsor to introduce the bill
mr chair i uh is casey connolly in the
room he's not he was here earlier
i i have been texting him and and he's
been uh anxious to speak i don't see him
on our list and if he's not in the room
i i would be happy to
introduce the bill because i do see mr
elliott berry is on the list ready to go
so if that's okay with you i'd be happy
to do that for you
please go ahead
uh so members of municipal and county
government my name is jim majorie
representing the town of northampton
rockingham district 22.
i thank you for your time and i'm happy
to introduce house bill 512
relative to the relative to emergency
housing assistance
and mr chair i did get a note from
representative connolly who is sprinting
down the hall
we'll
give him a couple minutes
no running in the halls
if i text him that he'll trip looking at
the phone
[Music]
well do we both uh speakers are in
support so why don't we go to uh
uh elliott barry and we'll follow up
with the
oh mr comic
okay mr chairman i'm ready you are ready
to go yes please
okay mr chairman committee members i'm
casey conley state representative dover
representing stratfor county district
13.
here now to introduce hbc 512
this bill would prohibit municipal
welfare or basically prohibit cities in
town from establishing
rules that require an inspection
as a stipulation for disbursing
emergency housing assistance funds
to new hampshire as the committee knows
statewide requires municipalities to
provide for
their residents
who are indigent
this is set up as sort of the last line
of support for people who have exhausted
other needs of assistance
this bill would uh or the law also
requires municipalities to enact
guidelines for providing that support
in some communities one of these
guidelines is a requirement that
dwellings be respected for code
compliance prior to providing housing
assistance
the purpose
is reasonable it's to ensure that this
rental housing is safe and livable
but landlords are under no obligation to
allow this inspection so as you can
imagine they could lead to people who
would qualify for assistance being
evicted from their homes because the
inspection is refused
uh and people who
uh essentially people would be evicted
who might otherwise be
uh who would otherwise be able to stay
the committee has heard a number of
bills this term already highlighting the
seriousness of the state affordable
housing crisis so i don't repeat that
um but the challenge in finding suitable
housing is more difficult after eviction
and this bill is intended to keep people
have homes in them during a time of
severe housing shortage in our state
finally mr chairman i would acknowledge
that
this is of course a unique time in our
state in our country there's
unprecedented federal support for
tenants this money is making itself
available in our state this is a good
thing
this bill is separate from that process
this is really intended to address
an ongoing concern not a concern that
necessarily is tied to the coverage
so with that i'm happy to
take questions and i ask to support
passage
okay so questions from representative
conway we have uh representatives davis
with her hand up
yes thank you mr chair and thank you
representative conley for taking my
question
um
i was going to offer an amendment or
proposed amendment to this bill that
would have added the word temporary be
before emergency housing assistance
but listening to your
testimony i'm thinking now that it may
be more appropriate
um to say something about the fact that
this is these are emergency housing
funds
that are being
supplied not in fact emergency
housing and i'm asking this question as
the
chair of the board of a large
social services non-profit here in the
upper valley we do a lot of housing
assistance
and
we have several different kinds of
housing assistance programs
none of them actually provide physical
housing they provide funding for people
to obtain physical housing so i guess my
question is
what exactly is the emergency housing
assistance that this bill anticipates
um representative thank you let me uh
try to answer that so
uh
in
the welfare office of a city or town
will often step in as sort of the last
me sort of the
with nowhere else to go that's where you
can you can attempt to find some
assistance
um
and as i noted uh and i was out of
breath rushing up here so forgive me but
um
the purpose is
there are this there's a hurdle in place
in some communities that prevents that
funding from being dispersed so
this is solely about cities and towns
and the municipal welfare assistance
um if i didn't answer that or if i
misunderstood your question please
please let me know and i'll try again
now um
follow up mr chair yes please thank you
now representative conley that that
definitely does answer my question
and i'm thinking that
give this bill the best chance of
success do you think that it would be
wise
to specify that these are emergency
assistance
and housing emergency assistance funds
and not in fact physical places did you
see the difference
representative i did not catch that
error in the bill i appreciate you for
pointing you know pointing it out and i
if it's i trust your um
i trust that you've identified something
that needs addressing so i would i would
support that that sounds fine
thank you
representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative cleanly i'm i'm a little
confused too if i'm understanding
correctly somebody is living in an
apartment or a home
and they experience hard times
and they go to
their town welfare office and ask for
financial assistance to pay their rent
this bill would prevent then the town
from saying we have to inspect the
premises first before we give you the
money
precisely and
okay
thank you
representative ninja booty
thank you mr chair thank you
representative connolly for taking my
question
does this
bill does not differentiate between a
renter or a homeowner if i'm a homeowner
i can't afford
to
code specific
changes but my tenant is unable to
stay there so would it would help either
way correct
uh yeah i presume it could help either
way
from understanding what you're saying
that that as a hormone i mean the owner
of that
rental unit that's falling apart but i
can't fix it
but i could make sure that so the
renter
tenant cannot be kicked out because it's
not code specific
because of my
undue diligence or i'm not able to
fix it
that scenario is a little bit different
than what's envisioned as a as a remedy
for this bill although the property
owner qualified
under the existing terms of that
particular town welfare
program then presumably yes
thank you
question from representative fleet
uh thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative conway for taking my
question uh i think it kind of
piggybacks on what uh representative
stavis had asked as well as
representative porter
so i just want to clarify
this is um emergency funds for a place
that i currently live in but can't pay
rent it's not the same thing as if
if you had a fire within the apartment
and we had to displace um the residents
there
and someone offered up
housing
i i guess what i'm saying is like what
happened in in manchester when they
tried to open up their police department
but they needed to have it inspected um
they opened up emergency housing but it
couldn't get inspected in time so this
would not qualify for that this would
just be qualified for someone who's
already in a place is that correct
yes again so uh to use a scenario if um
it's somebody approaches the
municipality for welfare assistance they
meet the income requirements and all
else uh everything is ready to move
forward but for this inspection which
the landlord is under no obligation to
allow the inspection to take place
under that scenario the tenant could
absolutely be evicted
despite the availability of support that
could not be utilized
okay next question
representatives davis
i'm good thanks
yes representative blind thank you for
coming to my question um
how does this deal with any possible
some standard housing that might be
available
not as a town protected about giving
funds for substandard housing we're
dealing with people are kind of in
crisis and that's why i put them in a
bad situation potentially yeah that's
thank you representative that's
definitely
we've thought that we i and others i've
worked with on this bill have really
been torn on that question because uh
it's absolutely a problem in our state
and it's a concern this really comes
down to
a
value judgment that some housing is
better than no housing this kind of
housing crisis time
and the fact that tenants under you know
any time whether or not they're up
against an eviction or not could pursue
a code complaint against their
landlord or property owner
um
yeah
representative
something like that i would hate to have
that okay for somebody to go in there
and live there without being inspected
question oh i'm sorry would i
thank everybody
i'd share that concern i would also
realize that
the conditions of the unit are what the
tenant has been living in presumably for
some time that has led up to this crisis
and
um
uh with the the birth of options for
people the lack of affordable housing
alternatives again it's it's a judgment
that that i that i'm putting out that
others may not agree with but that some
housing is better than latin
okay
next speaker we have is
the support of the bill
um
mr elliott barry from potential legal
assistance
thank you mr chairman can you hear me
okay yes you're doing fine go right
ahead thank you uh my name is elliott
berry i'm um the director of housing
justice at new hampshire legal
assistance i've been representing uh low
and moderate income tenants for 44
years it's a strange position for me to
be in uh and throughout those 44 years i
have
been promoting doing everything i can
to
help help low and moderate income people
obtain and maintain
decent affordable housing
and in a normal housing market i
wouldn't support anything like this
but we're not in the normal housing
market the median income for a
two-bedroom apartment statewide is one
thousand four hundred and thirteen
dollars a month the vacancy rate
statewide is one point eight percent
so if you apply you realize what a
a market like this causes
for low and moderate income people in
search of housing um you take another
i've had to take another look at this
local welfare recipients are generally
the poorest people in a municipality the
statute says you have to be poor and
unable to support yourself
by far the biggest line item
for most local welfare offices is rent
because there's nothing more
important to relief and maintenance than
is housing
these people who go to local welfare who
are the poorest in the municipality
generally live in poor housing because
that's all they can afford
um so what happens when they fall behind
in rent they go to the local welfare
department found eligible in some and
not all municipalities do this but some
do
they're eligible
conditioned upon an inspection
and passing the inspection
but many landlords don't cooperate with
the inspection or won't make the repairs
that are required
therefore the town doesn't assist
the tenant can't pay
the tenant gets evicted
and not only is the tenant poor and
unable to pay those very high rents all
over the place but now he or she has an
eviction on a record making it even more
unlikely that they can find any decent
place to stay and the result is too
often that they become homeless
most inspections in
in most cities and towns are based on
the fact that the tenant
made a complaint
um
it's up to the tenant to complain and i
think it's totally consistent with new
hampshire values to let the tenant be
the one to come make the complaint and
then if they do of course the housing
code department can do
and order repairs you know that are
appropriate under the housing code
but shouldn't a tenant who applies for
local welfare have the fair same choice
of whether or not to complain as any
other tenant
municipalities under this bill can still
re respond to tenant complaints or
neighbor complaints anytime
or a city is free to adopt with the
college certificate of compliance
program
where
every s every few years
on a staggered basis each rental unit is
um
inspected
to and get a certificate of compliance
if it meets code standards
undoubtedly the municipalities that do
impose a requirement
that there be an inspection prior to
granting local welfare assistance
is well intended
but it should not in practice become a
punishment
for a local welfare applicant
um who's seeking rental assistance when
the choice again when the choice is
substandard housing or no housing at all
regrettably terribly regrettably
i think we have to choose some housing
and
i heard your passage of the bill
let me say if i could that in response i
think it was representative davis to
indicate that we're talking about funds
not actual housing i think if we added
the phrase
um pursuant to rsa chapter 165
to paragraph two of the bill so it would
read no municipality shall require a
housing code inspection as a condition
of emergency housing assistance granted
pursuant to rsa chapter 165. under rsa
chapter 165 all assistance is by voucher
it's a promise to pay from the city to
the landlord
um and i think that would probably that
would take care of the uh of the
ambiguity but thank you for pointing
that out could you repeat that please
sure the language i would add to the
very end of the sentence
uh
the
words granted pursuant to rsa
chapter 165.
[Music]
165 yes thank you very much thank you
okay uh representative magic cody
thank you mr chair thank you mr barry
for taking my question
um this is at a point where
low income totally
uh
face
because of the housing shortage
in either eviction
which leads to homelessness or providing
the support at the most critical
place where we are trying to reduce the
number of homelessness
isn't uh can i make that assumption
you can and you said it better than i
did thank you
thank you
okay
next speak here mr chairman yes i'm
sorry representative
thank you for taking my question um
you're from uh legal assistance that's
correct what's the liability for the
town because uh it allows a citizen or a
resident to sit
in a it's a building that potentially is
not a state
if something happens is there any kind
of liability that would result back on
the town for a natural inspection and
confirming its success i've never seen a
case like that and in fact the cities in
every city and town in in new hampshire
today as we speak a number of households
are living in homes that are seriously
substandard
my question was oh the town sanctioning
this by giving them funds to stay in an
unsafe building because it didn't assume
any liability i don't think so i've
never seen it
and i should point out uh
i think this is helpful to know the
majority of municipalities do not do
this as far as i know and again i don't
think they've i've never heard of a case
where they've been found liable for
providing assistance to places that
don't need code
thank you uh representative maturity do
we have any members of the public that
have their hands raised that i can't see
on my screen
i do not see any other members of the
public mr chair
two members two members from our
committee though
uh representative imagined booty he had
a third question
i know sorry i didn't
put my hand down okay uh representative
please
uh thank you mr chair um
uh
my question is that uh currently if a
unit is what i would consider
substandard and i have seen some of
those
without the
request of the tenant the municipality
cannot do anything in other words we
can't force our way in or or anything to
that nature is that correct
i believe there is a procedure to get an
administrative warrant
uh but again that is something that
happens very very rarely um the other
thing that you should know just to
complete the picture though is that when
it gets to a situation where it really
is a um a serious threat to the health
and safety either of the residents or
or of the general public
the
municipalities usually through the fire
department but also sometimes to the
health department can bring in action to
actually they get cease and desist order
to move people out and they do that um
not often but when they do that happens
very quickly
thank
you okay see no further
hands up
uh make a note that the
blue so-called blue sheet has a support
of 91
the
[Music]
can you say that again please mr chair
it was broken up
sorry 91 support opposed three
so that concludes the hearing
on 5 12. we're going to now move it
right into the hearing for house bill
545.
this will be the last hearing of the day
i'm assuming that
for everything that the flame is the
planter
yes and should be all all set to speak
mr chair
okay please uh go right ahead
and
tell us
about the bill
thank you mr chair and good afternoon to
members of the committee and members of
the public
i'm here to introduce house bill 545
which is the exact same bill as
representative moynihan
had introduced last year
as house bill 1119
um that bill was reported out of the
committee
uh as off to pass 18-1
uh it was placed on the consent calendar
and was passed by the house by a voice
vote
and
went to the senate and got tabled as as
so many other bills were
during the testimony for house bill 1119
it was supported by the new hampshire
bankers association
as well as the new hampshire association
of counties
due to
mergers and acquisitions
the remaining there are four banks
remaining in new hampshire north of
lancaster
of the four
only one bank is state chartered
in coast county
the register of deeds the payroll
account the nursing home direct
residents of the nursing home direct
deposits
are
some of the
banking business
some of the deposits that are in local
banks
that are not state chartered
these accounts of course
all need to be transferred um and there
are people on
who can explain what that process is
going to be
uh especially the nursing home residents
um which the the money is held
in fiduciary trust by the county as i
understand
um
house bill 445
gives new hampshire counties and
municipalities
the
flexibility that they need so they can
utilize
banking institutions that are
local banks
with brick and mortar presences in the
towns
but are not charted uh in new hampshire
and that's the purpose of house bill 545
um and there are other people who are
willing to testify today who have a lot
more knowledge on the subject that i do
but i would be happy to answer any
questions from the committee to the
extent that i can give them an answer
any questions from the committee
seeing none uh let's go on to um
katie morgan who is part of the new
hampshire association of
counties that wants to justify the
support of this
thank you chairman dolan good afternoon
and to yourself and members of the
committee again my name is kate horgan
i'm the executive director of the new
hampshire association of counties which
represents all elected and appointed
officials in new hampshire's 10 counties
the new hampshire association would like
to register its support for house bill
545. as you've heard this would allow
new hampshire counties to expand their
banking opportunities to institutions
that may not be chartered in new
hampshire but are local banks for
example
bangor savings bank in colebrook was the
original first colebrook bank and has
been in the same location since 1889
yet it is unable to be utilized by coast
county as a banking institution because
it is not chartered in new hampshire
this is an extremely important
bill to our more rural and border
counties that have to drive extended
distances to complete county banking
while technological enhancements have
increased some banking access there are
still some items particularly our
nursing homes where we need to have cash
on hand and transactions cannot be
completed electronically it would also
allow us to seek out the best banking
opportunities for our counties we would
ask for your support for house bill 545
and i'm happy to take any questions all
right questions from this miss morgan
i'll be seeing that like let's move on
to
uh carrie and please that's pronounced
right remember the public
good afternoon chairman dolan and
representatives my name is carrie cleave
and i am the finance director for the
coast for coast county and the treasurer
for the town of columbia
i am support for hb 545. this is not an
issue with our rural municipalities
desiring to move our banking services to
out-of-state banks we are looking to
continue banking with our long-time
local banks that have merged with
neighboring out-of-state banks i am
going to give you two examples first
colebrook bank was established in 1889
in colebrook and in more recent years
expanded to southern new hampshire
markets
in amherst concord and portsmouth in
2015 first colebrook bank changed its
name to granite bank and in 2018 merged
with bangor savings bank a main
chartered bank
so wuganock bank was established in 1887
and had two branches in carlos county in
2006 pasumpsic bank a vermont chartered
bank merged with sawganok bank and in
uh some sick bank also merged with
lancaster national bank this is how
coast county's municipalities began
banking with vermont and maine chartered
banks that have a physical presence in
new hampshire i am looking forward to
your support thank you
any questions from ms
being done next
to speak is mr timothy felter from
newberry bank
and speaking supporters
good afternoon
hello go ahead go ahead mr phelps thank
you thank you chairman dolan and
honorable members of the house municipal
and county government committee
i appreciate the opportunity to speak
before you today my name is timothy
felter and i'm the senior executive vice
president chief financial officer and
treasurer of newburyport bank
we're a 1.2 billion dollar bank located
on the seacoast of new hampshire and in
northern massachusetts
while the bank is 167 years old
half of our branches have been opened in
new hampshire in just the past seven
years we have a branch in dover exeter
hampton and two in portsmouth
over the seven years the bank has
originated over 2.4 i'm sorry 246
million dollars of loans
while taking in 138 million dollars of
deposits in new hampshire our new
hampshire
payroll in 2020 for 37 employees was
over 2.7 million dollars
my point in all these facts is strictly
to point out that our commitment to the
state of new hampshire is as solid as
any of the institutions that may be
otherwise chartered out of states and
other places as well as in the state of
new hampshire
our bank has been a good corporate
citizen
during the last seven years we've made
charitable contributions of almost seven
hundred thousand dollars to new
hampshire and not-for-profit
organizations
and for example the bank recently
supported the mayor of the city of
portsmouth initiative the clippers
strong fund during the covet 19 pandemic
the bank has supported families first a
full service community health center
located in portsmouth for the past eight
years
our support of new hampshire
organizations is not limited time and
cash contributions we've also supported
the new hampshire cdfa through the
purchase of tax credits with purchase of
over 121 000 of tax credits to benefit
over 12 very worthy projects in the
state of new hampshire
i'm testifying here today
with the expectation of leveling the
playing field for our government banking
division
currently new hampshire laws require
banks charted in other states to post
collateral from new hampshire miscible
deposits
out-of-state banks which have national
charters don't have that same
requirement and so what we're looking to
do is is to see that banks are treated
fairly regardless of
our charters
sorry
we started our uh opened our government
banking business in 2019 we learned that
the playing field wasn't level
but we forged ahead anyways and what we
have done is
make sure that the additional collateral
requirements required by new hampshire
regulation
[Music]
are covered
in our costs and so as accordingly
the rates that we pay to our new
hampshire municipalities are lower than
what we pay in another state because of
the collateral requirements
so in fact it's not the bank that
necessarily suffers from this
requirement but is the local
municipalities which could be earning uh
more on their deposits a higher interest
rate
and so while the bill generally does
ensure fairness for tax paying
businesses in new hampshire there are
some aspects of the current version of
the bill that fall short of its
potential good to provide municipalities
with access to more banking choices
the our bank is generally supportive of
language in sections one a through d
however these sections need to be
modified in our opinion to be fair to
all banks regardless of charter
banks have played an important part in
our communities
our country's response to covet 19 and
community banks in particular have been
very supportive of local businesses
community support organizations and
individuals
we are committed to working with the
legislature to ensure that new hampshire
municipalities have the same opportunity
to get top quality banking services at a
fair price
while we agree with the spirit of the
bill we believe more refinement of the
language is necessarily necessary
particularly since it could have
unattended consequences which would
ultimately do a disservice to new
hampshire municipalities
thank you very much
thank you mr are there any questions
from the committee yes um
i don't see any
any questions from the public that
representative matt jury that you can
see that i can't see him ice cream
thank you mr chair we do have christy
merrill from the new hampshire bankers
association who would like to testify
but other than that i do not see any
questions
merrill you have the floor
lisa
good afternoon can you all hear me okay
yes please stay where you're from and
whether you support or oppose this bill
very good my name is christy merrill i'm
president of new hampshire bankers
association we are not officially taking
a position
mr chairman we also have our legal
counsel rob dietl from the gallagher
callahan and garcia law firm is it
possible to have him join me
yes
could you could you
give us his name again so we can put it
into minutes
rob dietl
spell the last name
that is d-i-e-t-e-l
okay his position is he's an attorney
yes he is uh legal counsel to the new
hampshire bankers association
okay thank you
all right afternoon committee can
everybody hear me
oh is this uh
this is attorney deedle okay go ahead mr
david i'll let christie speak i just
want to make sure everybody could hear
thank you okay
miss merrill
very good thank you so much mr chairman
as i said i'm president of new hampshire
bankers association we represent 37
state and federally chartered banks
which employ nearly 6 000 employees in
new hampshire
i just want to clarify that we were
involved in the legislation last year as
was stated but we did not have an
official position so we were very much
involved in the dialogue
and worked in the sponsor but we we
weren't officially taking a position
um and so attorney dietl is here today
and he can help answer any legal
questions as well
while we don't have an official position
we do come before the committee today to
respectfully ask that this bill be
amended
to allow for a study committee
turning house bill 545 into a study
committee will allow for more thorough
review and allow for input from various
stakeholders to ensure the proposal
creates a level playing field i would
like to say that we support the um we
understand that municipalities want to
have more banking options and we support
that but it is very complicated we want
to make sure that we get this
legislation right
so as i mentioned our membership
consists of new hampshire chartered
banks banks chartered in other states
and nationally chartered banks
municipal deposits is a very complex
issue and affects the members of
association in different ways depending
on their charter
under the current statutes banks banks
chartered in other states are limited
and the types of municipal deposits they
can accept while new hampshire charter
banks and nationally chartered banks
with a physical presence don't have the
same limitations
this proposal attempts to break down the
barrier these statutes currently create
giving out of state charter banks
greater access to municipal deposits and
you heard a little bit from newburyport
bank about about how that works
this bill is nearly identical to a
proposal from last year house bill 1119
and as i said we worked closely to the
sponsor to come up with a solution that
would create a level playing field for
all banks and the different charters but
in the end though we feel the bill did
not achieve that goal
and we asked the committee last year as
we did today to to to take a to make
that bill a study committee
what we are trying to do today is make
sure that the legislation does not harm
out-of-state banks that currently hold
municipal deposits
we also want to make sure that new
hampshire banks have comparable access
to municipal deposits in other states
and that's a very tricky point
and it's also important that the
municipalities that are seeking
additional options are not negatively
impacted by this legislation and we
understand that that is not the intent
here
in order to accomplish this we believe
it's important to carefully work with
the various stakeholders in order to
strike the right balance
um i do want to point out that in trying
to come up with a workable solution last
year
we did have conversations with the
treasurer since they play a role in this
and that conversation occurred with
former treasurer bill dwyer
we're unaware if any conversation like
that has happened with our current
treasure monica mezzapelli but
we believe that certainly would be
appropriate
and we understand that the rationale
behind this desire is to bring
bring in language that originates from a
constituent trying to adjust challenges
and their banking needs i understand
that there was an interest in placing
nursing home and prison residence funds
in a bank that's chartered out of state
and we did hear a little bit about this
um attorney dietl can speak to it but
after legal review and looking at the
exact existing statutes those funds are
not considered to be publicly owned
funds
and should be able to be deposited into
the county's bank of choice but we
understand the municipalities are
looking for additional options and we
are supportive of that intent
again we don't have a position overall
on the bill we do want to get it right
for banks that do business here and
that's why we're respectfully asking the
committee to amend the bill into a study
committee
um that ends my testimony and i will
take any questions and we'll um hand it
over to attorney diedel as well
okay oh i see two questions ferdinand 40
is your hand
thank you mr chair um this bill came
through us last year um and it's
i'm concerned that putting this into a
study committee will further delay the
relief that the um
the
counties and cities in uh
the north country have been experiencing
it's already been tape um tabled in the
senate last time and now if we put it
into a study committee that means that
it nothing will happen with it this year
and then it will be next year again
before that's three years to wait and
i'm concerned about that can you address
that lag in time and how
your association would recommend helping
these communities order
uh i i would ask i hear what you're
saying but it sounds like that's an
executive committee discussion i would
ask if you could formulate your comment
form of a question
i did i asked how they would recommend
the communities proceed while they're
waiting for this for this study
committee to come up with a solution for
them
um thank you for the question
representative our understanding as i
mentioned was that
the county was looking to place
prison resident funds and also
nursing home
to put their funds into and out of state
bank and our understanding is that they
have the ability to do that there may be
other concerns that i'm not aware of and
and like i said um you know we my
concern with this legislation as it's
proposed as it could have some
unintended consequences um and and you
heard a little bit from from newberry
port bank but in in this legislation i
think what's most important are two
goals um one is to make sure that the
public funds um the public's funds are
safe and sound and second is to make
sure that the funds are invested in
communities where they're generated and
so that's what this legislation tries to
do but we don't think that the solution
is quite right and because this is such
a big issue and that impacts so many
people
we do want to make sure that we help
those that need it but we also want to
make sure that we get it right this is a
statute these are many statutes that
haven't been changed in a long time and
so it very well may be time to to take a
broader um look at this but would just
want to make sure that we try to
anticipate any unintended consequences
christie this is this is rob dietl if i
can add on specifically in response to
rep porter's question um
i think it's important to note that
while the public testimony has focused
on county funds that the bill is
proposing amendments to i believe nine
different statutes that deal with state
funds county funds town and city funds
school treasurer funds
and they impact more than just the
specific issue that we believe has come
to light
in terms of
funds being held with respect to county
nursing facilities
they impact how funds are invested
deposited trust funds where capital
reserve funds can be placed to give you
an example of the level of complexity
here in rsa 29.1
there are a number of restrictions on
how counties specifically can deal with
their deposits and investments
currently county treasurers can place
those deposits in federally chartered
banks
in new hampshire banks
and out of state banks if they're
collateralized but investments are
limited to federally chartered banks and
new hampshire banks
and i highlight these points because i
think they really show that this is an
area that has evolved over a number of
years with various policy objectives
under the various types of funds that
are implicated and it's not a simple
solution from our perspective and that's
why we're asking in part for a study on
this
okay representative nanchikuri
thank you mr chair
uh having not been on this committee
last year
um
this is my first time and to understand
if it is it passed last year 18 to 1
and
these concerns have showed up now in
terms of trying to address the need for
our county and
residents of the
north country
specifically to
get a relief
so i'm kind of
puzzled as to how come this is such a
big
issue
and it wasn't
all right
thank you for the question we were
involved in the conversation last year
and we worked very closely with
representative wayne moynihan
you know attorney dietl can speak to
some of the complications here we argued
unsuccessfully last year for a study
committee ultimately the committee
wanted to move forward with the
legislation
and as the sponsor said it went to the
senate where it was placed on the table
so we did voice our concerns then as
well
it was we had engaged in many
conversations with representative
moynihan and the legislation went
through various iterations um before the
committee passed it and
we so we were part of that but um it's
just an evolving conversation and i
don't know attorney deedle is there
anything you'd like to add
what i will add is that the legislation
when it was advanced last year and it
has the same language in it this year
is dependent on the state treasurer
playing a role in accepting uh opinions
of counsel as to reciprocity and we had
some um detailed conversations with
previous state treasurer dwyer i'm not
sure if i know on the bankers
association side i don't believe those
conversations have occurred i don't know
to what extent the sponsor has had a
chance to connect with the treasurer but
i think that's an important point to
hear from the treasurer as well in terms
of
whether this structure is still an
acceptable structure
okay representative status thank you mr
chair
and i'm going to ignore the advice about
never ask a question you don't know the
answer to because i truly don't know the
answer to this question
but can one of the banking experts
testifying today
tell me where bar harbor bank is
chartered
sure representative this is christy
merrill i can try to answer that they
are chartered in maine my understanding
do business in new hampshire correct
correct
so how is that different
um i'm not quite sure i understand your
question if you're asking why is bar
harbor bank treated differently um i
think what it really comes down to and
where we struggled um is the is the
notion of reciprocity so um you know if
we take the states immediately around us
in maine um in vermont um attorney dieto
will tell you that
the laws there are reasonably comparable
so a new hampshire chartered bank that
does business over the border there
they would be able to
hold municipal deposits there are some
differences in the state of
massachusetts which make it a little bit
a little bit different and so part of
the challenge we have with this
legislation
is you know we originally went to the
banking department because
we thought they were a lot they would be
a logical arbiter to decide what is a
reciprocal treatment and we think that's
very important to make sure that all of
the banks have an equal playing field
and you know as the the banking
commissioner pointed out these statutes
are not located in the banking
department statutes they're scattered
among
the many statutes that have been
referenced earlier and so he did not
feel that was appropriate for the
banking department to really be the
arbiter and so that's where we ended up
with the treasurer's office and so
having um
you know an attestation having legal
counsel do an opinion and submitting
that attestation that they swear under
oath
that it is in fact uh reciprocal um then
you've heard newburyport banks talk
about how they have concerns about that
um that was a solution that was put
forward we're not sure if that's the
right solution or not but again we're
trying to really get at that that issue
of reciprocity
which is really important to make sure
that each of the states are playing um
in a similar manner and treat it the
same way follow up mr chair yes go ahead
i am thoroughly confused now
my question had to do with bar harbor
bank
which
up until a few years ago was called lake
sunapee bank
so what is the difference between is it
a difference between um
we like massachusetts less than we like
maine i i i just don't understand what
the objection is and and why the
objection wasn't raised
when bar harbor bank became lake sunapee
bank
the other way around
sorry
did you know the sellers
yes wasn't it the other way around bar
uh sun up he became bar harbor
i'm not sure
that is correct representative i i think
that's a similar situation
um i i don't know whether or not there
was
um complaints mentioned at that time but
obviously in the banking industry it's a
it's a trend here in new hampshire with
a lot of mergers and acquisitions and
that's a trend nationally we know that's
a concern and as i stated originally
we want we support the municipalities um
wanting to have additional banking
options but we just want to make sure
that we get all of our all of these laws
correct in doing so
okay thank you
see no additional questions
uh oh
do i see uh
no additional hands on the purpose there
patchy or the hands that i
i do not see any additional hands up
from panelists or from any of the
members of the public or attendees mr
chair
okay the public hearing on house bill
545 is uh complete
all right we're gonna go immediately
into executive sessions
so uh
i would ask
those members of the committee to pay
attention to
the bills that uh that i bring up and
we'll all have opportunities
mr chair is it possible to get a list
right now of the bills that we're going
to be executing now so that i can start
getting my papers out
yes
excuse me say it again
4 3 9 4 3 9
four six three
four six seven
[Music]
five one two
and 284
thank you sir
okay so uh
for
house bill 439
um
i'll look for a motion from
representative mccry
thank you mr chairman i would move that
uh otp
okay emotions would make otp
mr chairman i uh
second
otp on 439
okay uh discussion
any discussion on the video
remember what that bill was
okay
could you remind us please
representative gallagher
yes could you remind us please what that
bill was
this was the bill about
restricting the amount of authority that
local governments had
i think the
example
that was mostly discussed was around the
pandemic
issues that might come up
representative
thank you mr chair um i
i'm going to be voting i'm not going to
be voting in favor of the ought to pass
motion and my concerns are
are numerous about this but i will i
will limit it to if in the constitution
itself
the term general good is not defined
um and we look here at well-being as the
term which seems to be giving the the
sponsors the most grief
uh then then i then i i see uh i see no
reason to take that language out we
understood we understand from the
constitution
a general idea of what the general good
is and i think we should leave it to the
local municipalities
to have the flexibility to decide what
is in
what well-being means to their community
thank you thank you representative clay
your comment
uh thank you mr chair i um
also will be voting against ought to
pass
and i'll try to limit my comment
i i do have an issue with the fact that
it would mean that we would have to
bring the body together in order to come
up with a decision and in the case of an
emergency this could be quite
quite an undertaking um also in in light
of the fact that we don't have um
enough
i guess it was brought up about the
zoning laws etc etc so are we going to
have to each time we want to make any
changes to that have to come to the um
the board and um
i i just think that there's too many
pitfalls in it
thank you mr chair my comment echoes
both representative cleese and
representative maggiore
especially
the term well-being
i think it's there for a reason i don't
think it's a frivolous term as some of
the folks who testified before us
i i think it's a salient term in regards
to the health and well-being of a town a
municipality
called unincorporated space and the
people who live in those spaces can make
that judgment call
on the well-being the well-being of
dover might be very different than the
well-being of nashua
yet they are both
well-being and i will be voting no on
this
thank you representative magic
thank you mr chair um i will be voting
no on this uh to pass for a couple of
reasons one is the fact that on one hand
we are trying to push
fiscal responsibility to the local
control
and on the same token we're going to tie
the hands of the local government to
make
emergency decisions or ordinances to
safeguard the well-being of their
community just like my colleagues have
expressed
pandemic is a good example where nashua
did the right thing i feel safe my
constituents feel safe that was needed
and this will be taken away
uh if this bill passes for that reason
i'll be voting now representative porter
thank you mr chair
um
it was commented during the testimony
that
the government needs to be responsive to
the citizens
and that they that the
local government shouldn't be passing
ordinances that the citizens
don't want but it's the citizens of the
community that elect their
representatives to either the city
council or the select board or whatever
and they elect those people especially
in a city to be uh representative of
them
and make decisions for them that the
ten thousand people in the city can't
get together and make for themselves
to take away the local authority to make
ordinances takes away the voice of the
people who are elected to represent the
people so i i feel that it's
contradictory in nature and would be
detrimental to local control
thank you very much
i simply want to echo what
representative porter just said that was
exactly what i was going to say
okay uh representative
thank you mr chairman yes um
this bill is uh quite onerous to the
running of the local government uh
selectmen and
city council are elected by the people
to
make regulations
which are
um to the benefit of of that community
and
this puts too many
roadblocks in the
path of smooth running government
and it actually puts
roadblocks in
the legislature for
uh we would just be bogged down with so
much uh frivolous
legislation which is better off
done at the local level
thank you
do you have a motion otp it's the second
uh clerk
otp on hb 439
yes
representative tripp yes
representative mcbride
yes
representative melvin yes
representative
yes
representative power
representative porter
no
representative
no representative
no
representative
now
representative gallagher
no
and chairman
please have it uh
thank you uh next bill to
mr yes mr chair there will be a minority
report i'm not sure who will be writing
it
are you going to write the minority
report representative you said no
somebody will i'm not sure who but there
will be one
okay uh please send that to me for
approval uh my name is richard
yes
and uh representative mcbride you're
going to write the majority report
yes mr chairman
uh bill is
uh bill
467 you can say
this this was the issue with the
open space
and so forth
mr chairman
yes sir i remove itl for 463.
one second
[Music]
house bill 467 and there's an
ipl
you know gallagher has its hand up
um
i'm
i
am wondering um or i'd like to make a
motion to
table discussion
on this bill
until the
the sponsors indicated um
willingness to work on amending the
language to make it um
more
effective and um easier to pass and
i would like to the table discussion
until
they have had a chance to do that
on the table
table motion on 467.
no
what says no
representative trip no
representative guthrie no
representative los alas yeah
representative mcbride no
representative melvin
no
representative blank no
representative power no
representative porter no
representative
yes
no
representatives davis no
representative
yes
no
representative clay
representative
yes
the motion fails the table back to the
motion
of itl with the second
so no further discussion let's take
the vote is now ikea
[Music]
yes
representative guthrie
yes representative los alas yes
representative mcbride
yes
representative melvin yes
representative
yes
representative power yes
representative porter yes
representative trail 11
yes
representative pimentel
representative mijori
yes
davis
no
representative
yes
representative clee
representative gallagher
no
and chairman
yes
mr chair
we're still
[Music]
yes mr chair i believe the vote to table
was 14 to 5
not 13
to 6 as was reported
at least according to my account we'll
double check that thank you
and i believe representative lang has to
uh
yes with joe i'll be back at this i need
to run over to veggie action
present a bill
okay thank you
thank you for being here
[Music]
is house bill 463
which was the selectmen
appointing the town clerk that reached
the bell
this morning
so i'd like to uh look to
representative mcfry for motion
mr chairman i would move itl
motions i
[Music]
don't see any discussion
representative has her hand up
i do
all right yes i see it now uh
representative
please
thank you mr chair i had my real hand up
and
i couldn't coordinate myself to get the
other hand on
um
i'm conflicted about this bill
and i'm conflicted because
the son of gorham has
been thoughtful and done its work and
trying to think ahead
how things might work for them
and the tongue clerks association person
although he was
very um
persuasive
he's in favor of the way most people do
it and town clerks do it and he's not
necessarily
uh
sort of as i said before
got the well-being of gorham in mind he
may have the well-being of tom clerks in
mind and he was very
i think a little presumptuous when he
said well
someone will run don't worry someone
will run
well not necessarily someone will run
and
i'm loath to
to say no to a town that's trying to
find a proactive solution to
what they consider a problem the one
thing that i might
hope that they heard from the testimony
is that they could split those two
positions
and it might be easier for
two people to run than one person to run
for two jobs
um and again i'm still conflicted that's
my only commentary i'll listen to others
thank you
yes representative
yeah justin if i may i only can
go by my own experience but i think as i
said
in uh
in hampstead we had
a uh vacancy
was in between the elections
and we appointed somebody
and uh
they uh
subsequently
iran and it's been a very successful
town clerk after being trained
uh she's been with us probably
12 13 years
and
so
i i don't think goth
uh chrome has to uh worry too much about
a process to get a
a town clerk there
uh they'll get somebody as i know it's
just to say somebody will run but there
is somebody out there if you shake the
trees
and i don't think they have anything
to fear and i don't think this solves
their problem anyway
i think they still have to get somebody
who's qualified if they have to get
somebody to do the job whether it's by
appointment or election
uh they they have either vehicle and
right now
they have uh have election i
i just don't think we should make an
exception and i think they can work
around this
by talking to the town clerk tax
collectors that are on
uh board now and make sure that they
resign in between the election then the
town the town
fathers the town selectmen
can have some input
and uh go out and shake the trees and
get somebody to run
this is a comment from the chair um
i think uh one of the things that we
heard was you know
uh it was just reference was that they
won't be able to find somebody who's
gonna sign up
and get themselves on the ballot well in
cases like that i know in my town
we it's not uncommon to have
nobody running for certain collective
positions and we end up having a writing
campaign for somebody and whoever gets
the most writings wins
so you don't actually have to have
someone sign up for the election
and they can't pay for it which it
sounds like
what i always hear is right between the
lines that
certain people don't want to go through
the campaign and get signs and
all that stuff but this certainly
won't stop the
community from filling the position
through a writing campaign
uh representative clinton tell you that
comment
uh thank you mr chairman yeah i mean i'm
conflicted about this bill i understand
the sentiment
of the bill completely as a former
selectman
and um
unfortunately
i this is this is a kind of a bill that
really needs to go to a committee and
uh
really delve into it and try
to work out something
that'll work for all towns the big towns
the little towns
um
yeah uh
i'd love to vote for for gorham but i
just don't believe in
just carving out a little thing for one
one town i think we need a a bigger bill
to take care of it for all of new
hampshire
thank you um
before we take a vote let me go back a
little too fast here on house bill 467
that just
was voted to ipl by 17 to two of them
asked president mcbride to write the
majority report
do i have a volunteer on one of those
two to write the minority report
as one of the minorities i don't
see any reason to write a minority
report
yeah i don't see a reason to write a
minority part either
we have we have to have one so um
let me
let me have some
we don't need to have a minority report
only a majority report especially on a
bill this close
at least in the past if you noticed in
the calendar that we just voted on on
thursday there were a number of bills
who had no minority reports i'll double
check on that but uh thanks
yeah that that's my recollection too so
uh
we're back with uh house bill 463
there's a bit of motion to ipl in a
second is there any additional comments
before we take a vote
are you seeing that ask the clerk to
follow
yes losales yes
representative mcbride
yes
representative melvin yes
representative representative power yes
representative porter
yes
representative trail oven
reluctantly yes
yes
representatives davis
representatives davis i apologize yes
representative magda puti
yes
representative fan
representative clee
yes
gallagher
and chairman
yes
18 to 0.
all right 18-0
gonna ask representative mcbride to
write the committee before there is no
minority or requirement objection nope
i'll take care of it
those all those reports minority and
majority have to be sent to me first i
have to approve them and i'll send them
on to uh
the representatives mcdonald and
and they and ourselves
mr chair
yeah can uh
hp 467
no
463 go on consent calendar it's 18 to
nothing with no fm
okay the next bill
that we're going to consider is
hd 512
that was the one about the
code
issues with assigning emergency housing
mr chair
representatives davis had mentioned
wanting to get an
amendment maybe for this um
can you literally you still want to do
this
um i've actually sent the proposed
amendment to ols and they're working on
thank you i didn't hear you
all right
you went to ols and then i didn't hear
anything after that they are they are
working on the amendment
is there a
is there a recommendation that we uh
maybe accept this on wednesday if we
give ourselves a couple of days to get
that amendment in order
that would be good
mr chair my husband just walked in
from his
back from work just want to let you know
thank you
all right our next build to an executive
session will be
uh
helps build 545 it's the one we just
heard about on banks
uh look to uh
representative monday for a motion uh
i'll make a motion pass on house bill
545 uh
representative
uh second
most immediate second is there any
discussion on that though
before we take a photo
so
since it's been a long time wait some
relief up north
i think that uh
you deserve a break that assembly gets
your change
in the senate
that bill if you remember uh bill number
1119 last year's past 18 to 1 on the
committee
in this particular bill
on the blue sheet we had 18 support zero
opposed to neutral
just for reference
is there any comment before you take the
vote yes representative uh
is it patchy dory
yes
thank you mr chair i i just wanted to
emphasize that i i grabbed i guess one
of the benefits of working from home is
access to records and i grabbed the bill
from from when we first saw it the
original bill and the amended bill
and
uh if anybody has any concerns about
what we heard from the businesses from
the banking association it seems all of
their concerns or i i hope i don't want
to argue with an attorney as i am not
one and would lose that battle every day
and twice on sunday
but it seems that all of their concerns
were addressed in the amendment
according to all of my notes and the
bill that we have in front of us 512 is
that amended bill so uh i i
just wanted to pass that along to the
members thank you we're actually leaving
545.95
545 i'm sorry you're right okay just
want to make sure
this is going out live because people
are writing notes down to get them right
so uh
since there seems to be no further
discussion i'll ask this clerk to take a
role on otp on house bill 545
okay uh
representative
yes
yes representative
representative guthrie yes
yes
representative mcbride
melvin yeah
representative
yes
representative porter yes
representative
yes
representative mattel
representative
yes
representative davis
representative megan
[Music]
yes
unless there's an um i will put that on
the consent calendar
if you want to write the committee
report
okay the next bill we're going to
consider an executive session is house
bill 262.
uh if you remember that's that was uh
the deal brought forth by uh
representative
that was changing lot sizes
in some cases to minimum size one acre
across the state
mr chair i think that's
284 you're discussing
lots is 284.
i think 262 is the one requiring
uh rsas be put on
right the bylaws bill that all the
bylaws refer to an rsa
right
yes
yes thank you
this is managing this committee
you should write a book
hey mr chair we do have an amendment on
that bill am i correct
yes sir we have one do we
um i have uh
zero four five
h
2021-04568
amendment to hb 262.
so
can you convey to us who are in the dark
as to what that amendment is
i don't think i have that
i i i will i can read it
and if i can find it i can email it but
yeah um is it a long amendment
it is not um it begins
on line nine
and it says uh it is amending the the
language that was already in bold and it
now says every bylaw and ordinance
enacted or amended after the effective
date of this introductory paragraph
shall state the rsa section that enables
such bylaw or ordinance however
if the applicable rsa section is
subsequently renumbered no change shall
be required in such bylaw or ordinance
as suddenly has now appeared
brightly in front of all of us thank you
to
dina
christina
uh representative could you read about
the amendment number as well
especially for me and the clerk
happy to do so it is 0
2 1
0 4
5 6
h
thank you you're welcome
all right so uh
don't you have to do the amendment first
only if only the amendment only applies
if it's an otp
thank you
i move uh itl on house bill 212.
262.
is there a second from
representative mcbride
second
the motion's been made and second into
itl if the motion to itl fails then then
we'll take up the amendment in a
different emotion
thank you mr chair
um
is it just other is there any discussion
on the ital portion of 262.
okay uh it'll on 262
uh representative
work for cs
representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie yes
representative salas yes
president
yes
representative porter
oh excuse me
yes
uh representative 311
yes mr clerk
thank you ma'am
representative pimentel
motion to itl that would be a yes
representative majority
yes
representatives davis yes
states that's our opportunity to you
yes
thank you ma'am
representative mangapudi
yes
representative vance
representative clee
yes
representative
okay without
any
objection i'll place that on consent
18-0
and
[Music]
i ask you to write the media report
represent a cell will write the
committee
thank you the next bill we're going to
discuss is
house bill 284 which is the one that i
was
erroneously spoken about before this is
the one about the eighth change in the
acreage uh the minimum watt size
this was uh representative
bill
um i
i think that's a different bill um that
this is about involuntarily merged lots
well um i think we already voted on the
minimum lot size one
this is great mcbeath's
bill not representative yokela's
right
132 from christ
that's right 284 was the one that had
the
extended the date additional two years
to get it done yes there was some
discussion about
i know nhma opposed that they said they
had long enough and there was some other
um
discussion about
that maybe there should be any
sunset so it was kind of a wide
thought process around that so
i'd like to uh
i'd like to look to uh representative
loseless for emotion mr chairman i move
we retain
house bill 284
and uh is there a second
second
representative power second says other
discussions on the motion to retain
mr chair i would like to hear why
someone wants to retain this bill be
curious
i just think that it needs more work
that it's uh not ready to
uh vote either up or down
let me also say that it seemed to be a
wide
there wasn't a lot of consensus around
yeah we should do this or maybe we
should adjust it a little bit it was
my
disagreement between
uh no extension to a two-year extension
to a 10-year extension
so it looks to me like it needs to uh
that
that kind of discussions into support
any other discussion on the motion to
retain uh yes
representative yes mr chair yes please
go ahead
thank you
i'd like to ask
again i don't know that representative
porter's question was answered why would
we retain this bill
to do more work on it all it does is
extend
a practice that's already in place
so it it it supports a practice that
landowners have been using and cities
and towns have been satisfied with and
this extends it for two years
why would we stop it
why would we not allow this to continue
to happen
uh i think uh
the reason a rationale is um
one of the rationales is that
we we're not close to consensus on this
representative
i'm sure
i was going to say that
it seems silly to only do it for two
years i would i would suggest that we uh
extend it another 10 years or or and
definitely extend it
well i'd be in favor of that yet i don't
know if that we're at a point where we
can amend this bill right now without
bringing in a new one i'll be quiet
representative
kerr with what i just heard because it's
what i was going to say it seems like an
amendment to this
could be could be done under the terms i
just heard 10 years or indefinitely or
we just
kill it but retaining the bill i i i
think we could do the work that would be
done in that time frame with it with an
amendment
uh representative porter
yes mr chair is going to agree with what
representative
maggiore just said of if our we can just
make an amendment it's it
we might have to hold until wednesday
the executive but
if we retain it we're just going to make
an amendment to extend it
i mean there might be other discussion
that was had that i'm not familiar with
but right now what i'm hearing is we
think it's a good idea but it's not long
enough so we want to fix it make it
longer or make it indefinite and then
you know if that's the issue then an
amendment could be
done
what what are you what are you all those
of you who want to amend it where do you
think you want to offend it too
hide i'd amend it to 10 years or in
perpetuity
personally
uh we have consensus around that what i
don't want to go through is go through
an ols amendment and then just kill it
on wednesday i want to make sure we have
some type of consensus given the
calendar that we're facing
uh representative clee what are your
thoughts
unmute
i'm sorry i agree with my my colleagues
um
i i think i i have no problems with 10
years or in perpetuity um i i think to
retain this to only basically do an
amendment later on in the in the fall
just um or next year seems um
like better use of our time and i would
just recommend an amendment and i'm okay
with 10 or forever
[Music]
i'd like to recommend in perpetuity i
don't see any reason why we should ever
stop the the separation of involuntary
involuntarily merged lots i i don't see
that there's anything in it for us
and a lot of grief for other people so
my recommendation is an amendment saying
that involuntarily merged lots can be
unmerged at the landowner's request in
perpetuity
so is there is there consensus across
the committee for
perpetuity
if there is we we uh look for a
volunteer to run that event that's more
or less and we'll come back and we can
hopefully get a unanimous vote on that
who would like to volunteer to work with
ols on that amendment
representative van might like to do it
representative van may do it i will
write an amendment and get it to ols
later this afternoon all right then
let's plan on accepting uh that bill on
wednesday with an amendment
that sounds good to everybody
sounds good to me
if it makes you feel any better mr chair
we were pretty unanimous that we wanted
to
pass the bill
we saw no reason to kill that bill so
and the discussion we had was all about
making it perpetual so
thank you on our side we're okay i don't
know how you are on your side but
okay uh the last bill i want to talk
about is uh
house bill 512
health care lab
the emergency one emergency housing
assistance
i thought we already talked about that
yeah i thought we were um
as a representative staff that sent out
a amendment for that and we were waiting
for
three
three three to
executive
representative
was going to work that amendment
i said that a few minutes ago mr chair
okay got it all right we'll plan on
wednesday as well
another one that
i'm going to wait till wednesday on its
uh house bill 431
we heard this morning about the elected
animal control officer
i just think that that one
is of
get some very interesting testimony and
i just thought we needed more time
so we'll accept that one on wednesday
hey
i think that's it
mr chair my husband is now in the office
with me if you see a stranger walking
around that's who it is
okay on on wednesday we are
scheduled to meet at nine o'clock
but next monday uh let's not forget it's
gonna sneak up on 8 30 our start time
next monday
10 30. we have three budget bills to
hear
that the sponsor is working to combine
all three of those into one bill and
that's why uh it's written out the way
it is you try to be a little more
efficient especially when we get to the
general session we'll have
the plan would be to
hopefully
have one bill come out of that
and two of them would be itl so we'll
reduce it from three to one
we'll see it may not happen that's
that's what the tide is at this point
we'll try to make ourselves a little
more efficient when we get to the floor
representative your hand is up here
another comment
no sorry i just failed to put it down
okay that's fine all right thank you
very much i'm going to conclude the
executive session at this point and look
forward to seeing you all on wednesday
morning mr chairman yes do you know
where we will be meeting our wednesday i
believe it's you
[Music]
oh are we finished mr chair are you john
thank you very much